bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat des yaourts plus sucrés
ou encore des dates de péremption
allongé sur certains produits le
Parlement a mis définitivement un terme
à ces pratiques alimentaires
discriminantes pour les autres mèes en
adoptant définitivement une proposition
de loi socialiste allant dans ce sens
après un dernier vote du Sénat le 21 mai
dernier retour donc ce matin sur
l'adoption de cette proposition de loi
qui vise à garantir la qualité
alimentaire des outr-merses bonne
science à tous l'ordre du jour appelle
la discussion de la proposition de loi
adoptée par l'Assemblée nationale visant
à garantir la qualité de l'offre
alimentaire en
outrem dans la discussion générale la
parole est à à Monsieur Victorin Lurel
ministre de
l'outrem Monsieur
président
merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur dans la
commission des affaires
sociales mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
c'est une proposition de loi
importante qui est soumise aujourd'hui à
votre
examen c'est un texte de santé publique
et c'est aussi un texte
d'égalité qui vise à mettre un terme à
des pratiques discriminantes qui visent
les outres depuis bien trop
longtemps en effet depuis des années
les habitants des autres mers consomment
des aliments principalement des boissons
et des spécialités laitières qui
présentent des surdosages en sucre par
rapport au même produits de même marque
commerciale commercialisé en France
hexagonale depuis des années des
citoyens français sur des territoires
Français consomment dès leur plus jeune
âge des aliments et des bois dont la
composition en sucre a des effets
désastreux sur la santé comme le prouve
la prévalence du diabète et de l'obésité
outremre et depuis des années après
l'indifférence nous entendons les
dénégations des industriels qui
n'hésitent pas à affirmer que les
habitants des outremèes sont comme
naturellement plus friants de sucre que
les autres français et qui ils sont
eux-mêmes demandeurs de ces
excès ce texte de loi est la seconde
tentative de mettre un terme à ces
pratiques il y a 2 ans à l'Assemblée
nationale malgré des faits des analyses
des chiffres malgré des enquêtes
épidémiologiques malgré des preuves
incontestable qui avait suscité la
stupéfaction des députés qui découvrait
les existance de ces pratiques à
hurissante la proposition de loi que je
défendais alors comme parlementaire
avait été rejeté à quelques voix
près et pourtant nous ne demandions
qu'une chose que les taux de sucre dans
les aliments et les boissonsromè soi
aligné sur ce pratiqué dans
l'Hexagone outre les raison purement
euh politicienne qui furent à l'origine
de ce rejet inextrémiste
les arguments d'alors sont à peu de
choses près ce que nous avons pu
entendre de nouveau en commission et
dans les débats à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est du domaine du réglementaire un
simple décret et le tour est joué
pourquoi ne pas conclure des chartes de
bonne conduite avec les
industriels nous étions en octobre 2011
et je le dis avec
gravité nous avons perdu un temps
précieux durant lequel il ne s'est rien
passé
rien ni décret ni engagement volontaire
des industriels j'ai CR comprendre qu'il
y a une accélération depuis quelques
semaines puisque on aorté à ma
connaissance que quelques chares
auraient été signé ici ou là et les
pratiques condamnables ont
perduré il revient donc au Sénat
de permettre de les faire cesser en
adoptant à son tour cette proposition de
loi qui va dans le sens de l'un des 30
engagements du Président de la
République
elle bénéficie du soutien du
gouvernement que j'ai exprimé à
l'Assemblée nationale avec mon collègue
Guillaume Garot qui je le précise au
passage vous prie de l'excuser car il
est retenu par d'autres obligations oui
mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs ce texte mérite d'autant plus
d'être voté
qu'il a été sensiblement étoffé et
amélioré par rapport à sa version 2011
grâce au concours des parlementaire et
en particulier la députée de la
Guadeloupe Hélène vainqueur Christophe
qui en était la rapporteur à
l'Assemblée il ne vise plus uniquement à
réguler les taux de sucre ajoutés mais
il porte désormais plus largement sur
l'amélioration de la qualité de l'offre
alimentaire outremer et c'est toujours
dans une optique
d'égalité car en travaillant sur le
sujet d'autres discrimination frappant
les outremèes dans le domaine
alimentaire ont été mises en
lumière une autre pratique condamnable
celle des dates de limite de
consommation
différencié pour un même produits vendu
dans l'Hexagone et exportés dans les
outremers cette pratique consiste à
prolonger la date limite de consommation
de certains produits à
l'export à l'origine lesout était visé
car certains ont une date limite de 30
jours à Paris ou ailleurs dans
l'Hexagone quand elle peut-être de 50
jours à Saint-Denis ou à fort- de-fance
mais à mesure que le sujet a été fouillé
et
expertisé ce sont en réalité plus de 300
produits frais qui font l'objet d'une
date limite de consommation différencié
plus de 300 produits frais et la
différence peut aller de quelques jours
à plusieurs
mois ainsi tel fromage j'espère que ici
dans cet hémicycle vous n'allez pas le
prendre comme une stigmatisation mais le
reblouchon pour être précis est-il
commercialisé avec une DLC de 35 jours
dans
l'Hexagone et de 70 jours dans les prire
du simple au
double ainsi tel sachet de gruillère
râppé avec une DLC de 40 jours dans
l'Hexagone est-il commercialisé avec une
DLC de 180 jours 180 jours cela peut
donc aller d'un mois et 10 jours à plus
de 6
mois comment peut-on encore tolérer
cela bien sûr cela pose la question de
l'égalité dans la République mais cela
pose une autre
question une autre question qui est au
cœur des réflexions actuelles sur le
gaspillage
alimentaire si les DLC pour les outremè
apparaissent à l'évidence si longue
c'est peut-être aussi que celles en
vigueur dans l'Hexagone sont trop
courtes et que l'on envoie ainsi à la
poubelle des tonnes d'aliments encore
sains
les industriels doivent au consommateurs
la
vérité et la transparence sur ce
sujet nous y reviendrons j'en suis sûr
dans nos
débats on peut évoquer les Manes de de
chpéter la destruction
créatrice on peut trouver des arguments
en faveur de l'emploi mais ça mérite
d'être posé et un débat public devrait
être à mon sens
engagé enfin je tiens à souligner une
disposition tout à fait importante qui a
été ajoutée dans durant les débats en
commission à l'Assemblée nationale
l'obligation qui sera faite aux
collectivités de tenir compte du critère
de performance en matière de
développement des approvisionnements
directs en produit de l'agriculture dans
l'attribution des marché de restauration
collective cela concerne aussi bien les
cantines scolaires les hôpitaux ou les
restaurants
d'entreprise cette disposition présente
l'intérêt de participer à la
structuration et au renforcement des
filières de production euh locale ainsi
ce sont notamment les fruits et légumes
produits localement en circuit court qui
verront leur accès favorisé avec des
garanties de volume significatifs
et c'est favorable à un
développement comment disait-on
endogène le postulat est intéressant une
meilleure qualité nutritionnelle de
l'offre alimentaire dès le plus jeune
âge peut-elle aller dans le sens d'une
stratégie offensive de développement des
économies des outremerses pour toutes
ces raisons ce texte je le répète est un
texte important très
important je tiens à saluer le travail
conséquent et remarquable qui a été
conduit par le Sénat et en particulier
sa présidente Annie David ainsi que son
rapporteur Michel
Vergos nous espérons que cette
proposition de loi sera très vite
adoptée afin qu'elle soit opérationnelle
très vite et qu'elle puisse contribuer à
améliorer l'offre alimentaire dans les
outremèes je vous
remercie merci monsieur le ministre dans
la suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à Monsieur Michel Vergos
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre madame la Présidente de la
Commission mes chers
collègues les consomm ultramarins sont
frappés par une double
inégalité quant à la qualité des
produits alimentaires auxquels ils ont
accès ces inégalités sont
inacceptables d'autant qu'elles sont
susceptibles d'entraîner des effets dé
faste sur la santé des
personnes la première de ces inégalités
concerne la teneur en sucre de certains
produits alimentaires en Martinique des
yaourts au fruits produit localement
contiennent ainsi de 27 à 50 % de plus
de sucre
ajouté que les spécialités comparables
disponibles dans
l'Hexagone de fait la recette de
certains produits est adaptée lorsqu'ils
sont distribués sur le marché ultramarin
en raison d'une prétendue
préférence pour le sucre des
consommateurs des Outremers que les
industriels appellent le goût
local or plusieurs indices tendent à
démontrer qu'il est nécessaire de
limiter la consommation de sucre pour
protéger la santé des personnes les plus
fragiles des études ont en effet mis en
évidence le rôle spécifique de la
consommation de boissons sucré dans
l'apparition du surpoids et de l'obésité
chez l'enfant
selon l'Organisation Mondiale de la
Santé le surpoid et l'obésité
constituent d'importants facteurs de
risque pour le développement de
certaines pathologies non transmissibles
et chroniques tels que le diabète les
troubles musculos selettique certains
cancers et surtout les maladies
cardioovasculaires qui représentent la
première cause de décès dans le monde au
total selon un rapport de l'Agence
française de sécurité sanitaire des
aliments de
2004 il est certain qu'un régime
alimentaire présentant un index ou une
charge glycémique élevé a je cite des
effets délétaires sur la santé au moins
dans certaines catégories de la
population comme les sujets en surpoids
et les personnes
diabétiques plusieurs organismes ont
d'ailleurs émis des recommandations
concordantes pour diminuer la quantité
de sucre consommer chaque jour et
notamment de sucres ajoutés dans sa
stratégie mondiale de 2004 pour
l'alimentation l'exercice physique et la
santé l'OMS recommande ainsi au pouvoir
public d'adopter des mesures pour
réduire la teneur en sucre des boissons
et en cas nous sommes conscients que
l'obésité est un problème de santé
multifactoriel qui ne pourra être
endigué par la seule baisse de la teneur
en sucre de l'offre alimentaire
cependant au regard de ces éléments il
semble nécessaire
d'intervenir la question est d'autant
plus importante que la fréquence du
surpoids de l'obésité du diabète est
particulièrement forte parmi les
populations ultramarines la prévalence
de l'obésité atteindrait 22 % en
Martinique 23 % en Guadeloupe alors
qu'elle n'est que de
14,5 %
l'Hexagone l'obésité touche
particulièrement les femmes et les
enfants 9 % des enfants seraient obèes
en Guadeloupe et en Martinique contre
3,5 % dans l'Hexagone soit près du
triple par ailleurs les outromè figurent
en France parmi les territoires les plus
touchés par l'épidémie de
diabète quelques mesures timides ont été
prises au cours de ces dernières années
pour remédier à la progression constante
de ces problèmes
lié à l'excès de poids elles
apparaissent cependant très
insuffisantes ce qui justifie une
intervention législative visant à mettre
en œuvre des mesures plus
contraignantes le Programme National
Nutrition Santé PNNS qui existe depuis
2001 et le plan obésité ont fait l'objet
d'une déclinaison spécifique en directec
des populations
d'outrem si les mesures préconisées se
sont traduites par plusieurs initiatives
intéressantes au niveau
local les effets de ces instruments
tardent à se faire
sentir des actions ont également été
prises en direction des industriels de
l'agroalimentaire dans le cadre du
PNNS 2 et du programme national pour
l'alimentation sur la base du vol
il leur a été proposé de signer des
chartes visant à améliorer la qualité
nutritionnelle de leur production
cependant à l'heure actuelle une seule
charte concernant spécifiquement la
question des taux de sucre dans les
produits distribués en outr a été signé
la méthode de la
concertation semble donc avoir atteint
ses
limites la seconde inégalité qui frappe
les consommateurs ultramarins concerne
les dates limites de consommation
quelques industriels apposent sur les
produits très périssables qu'il fabrique
sur le continent comme par exemple les
yaourts un étiquetage indiquant une date
limite de
consommation différente selon que ces
produits sont destinés au marché
hexagonal ou au marché ultramarin ainsi
tandis que l'étiquetage de la plupart
des yaourts distribués en France
hexagonal compte une comporte une date
limite de consommation calculée en
fonction d'un délai de 30 jours à
compter de leur date de fabrication ce
délai peut atteindre 55 jours soit
pratiquement le double pour les mêmes
produits lorsqu'ils sont commercialisés
en
outreem si cette pratique ne concne ne
concerne heureusement qu'un nombre
restreint de fabricant elle pose une
question de principe qui ne peut être
négligé d'autant qu' pourrait être à
l'origine de risques sanitaires
inacceptables en effet selon le droit
communautaire les produits
microbiologiquement très périssables
tels que les yaourts je cite sont
susceptibles après une courte période de
de présenter un danger
immédiat pour la santé humaine c'est
pourquoi une date limite de consommation
de leurs produits doit être déterminé
par les industriel eumême sous leur
responsab
et à partir d'analyse de risque
or dans le cas de la pratique de la
double date limite de
consommation la fixation d'une date plus
éloignée pour les produits destinés aux
marchés ultramarins répond à une
préoccupation uniquement commerciale les
denrées produites en France hexagonale
doivent en effet être acheminés par
bateau vers ces marchés ce qui implique
un délai de transport conséqu
la date limite de consommation de 30
jours est donc souvent presque atteinte
lorsque ces denrées atteignent leur
destination pourtant de telles modalités
de transport impliquent un risque
sanitaire plus important en raison
notamment des risques de rupture de la
chaîne du froid en toute logique la date
limite de consommation des produits
destinés au marché ultramarins devrait
être rapproché et non reculé la pratique
de la double date de limite de
consommation résulte donc d'une
interprétation erronée faite par les
industriels de la régmentation
applicable et qui pourrait exposer les
populations ultramarines à un risque
sanitaire
inacceptable on peut également relever
que la présence sur le marché ultramarin
de produits provenance de France
hexagonale et indiquant un délai de
consommation plus long que le délai
habituellement utilisé constitue une
concurrence déloyale à l'encontre des
producteurs locaux qui respectent ce
délai ce sont ces inégalités que la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui vise à corriger le texte
initial reprenait en partie les
dispositions de la proposition de loi
déposée par monsieur vitorin Lurel à
l'Assemblée nationale qui avait été
adopté en commission des affaires
sociales avant d'être rejeté à 9 voix
près en séance publique en octobre
2011 à l'origine il concernait
uniquement la question de la teneur en
sucre des produits alimentaires
disponibles sur le marché ultramarin
lors de l'examen du texte à l'Assemblée
nationale sont venus s'ajouter le sujet
des doubles date limite de consommation
et celui de la qualité nutritionnelle
des repas distribués par les entreprises
de restauration collective au total le
texte qui nous est proposé porte sur la
question plus globale de la qualité de
l'offre alimentaire en outreomè ce dont
je me
félicite les dispositions du
texte seront applicables dans les
collectivités mentionnées à l'article 73
de la Constitution soit la Guadeloupe la
Martinique la Guyane la Réon Maillotte
ainsi qu'à saintebthelémie sa
Saint-Martin et Saint-Pierre
etmiquelon son article 1er vise à fixer
une teneur maximale en sucre ajouté pour
les produits alimentaires distribué dans
les outr-mers par référence à la teneur
maximale constatée dans les produits
comparables commercialisé dans
l'Hexagone deux catégories de produits
sont concernés par ce plafond d'une part
les denrées similairire et de même
marque distribué à la fois en outromè et
dans l'Hexagone d'autre part les denrées
alimentaires exclusivement distribué
dans les outremers et assimilable à
celle de la même famille commercialisé
dans l'Hexagone dont la liste sera
précisée par voie réglementaire dans le
cas où la teneur en sucre ajouté des
denrées équivalentes distribué dans
l'Hexagone diminuré une période
d'adaptation d'une durée maximale de 6
mois est prévu afin de permettre aux
opérateurs d'écouler leurs stock le
contrôle de ces dispositions est confié
aux agents publics compétents notamment
à ceux de la distribu de la direction
générale de la concurrence de la
consommation et de la répression des
fraudes monsieur le ministre lors de la
préparation de ce texte mon attention a
été attirée sur le fait que la
DGCCRF qui fournit un travail
remarquable fait face à la fois à un
élargissement de ses compétences et à
une réduction de ses moyens cet effet de
ciseau pourrait être susceptible
d'entraver la pleine application de ce
texte afin de permettre aux industriels
d'adapter leur production aux nouvelles
contraintes l'article 2 fixe un délai de
transition de 6 mois à compter de la
promulgation du texte ce qui me semble
raisonnable l'article 3 concerne les
dates limites de consommation il prévoit
que lorsque la mention d'une date
indiquant le délai dans le une denrée
alimentaire doit être consommée est
apposé sur l'emballage ce délai ne
peut-être plus long que celui prévu pour
la même denrée de même marque distribué
en France
hexagonale pour lever toute ambigué de
rédaction pouvez-vous monsieur le
ministre nous préciser que la
formulation retenue concerne bien les
dates limites de consommation figurant
sur les EMP
des denrées alimentaires
microbiologiquement très périssables et
non les fameuses DLUO les dates limite
d'utilisation optimale qui sont utilisés
pour les produits qui présentent une
relative stabilité
microbiologique l'article 4 enfin vise à
rendre obligatoire pour l'attribution
des marchés publics de restauration
collective la prise en compte des
performances en matière de développement
des approvisionnements direct de produit
de
l'agriculture l'article 53 du code des
marchés publics prévoit déjà que les
pouvoirs
adjudicateur peuvent prendre en compte
ce critère pour déterminer l'offre
économiquement la plus
avantageuse rendre ce critère
obligatoire permettra de promouvoir une
meilleure qualité nutritionnelle de
l'aufre alimentaire en restauration
collective en favorisant
l'approvisionnement en produits fr FR et
de saison et à incité aussi au
développement des filières agricoles
locales en encourageant le développement
des circuits courts au total cette
proposition de loi constituera un pas
important pour l'amélioration de la
qualité nutritionnelle de l'offre
alimentaire à destination de populations
ultramarines particulièrement touché par
le surpoid et l'obésité elle permettra
surtout
d'assurer enfin l'égalité entre les
consommateurs et c'est pourquoi je vous
demande au nom de la commission des
affaires sociales d'approuver ce texte
je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Madame Annie David pour
le groupe
CRC
ça
va monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur mes
chers
collègues cette proposition de loi que
nous étudions aujourd'hui que Monsieur
le Ministre et monsieur le rapporteur
viennent de nous présenter dans le
détail doit être appréhendé pour mon
groupe sous deux angles il s'agit bien
sûr d'une part d'une question de santé
publique et d'autre part d'une question
de pouvoir d'achat les chiffres je
commencerai par la question de santé
publique les chiffres qui nous ont été
communiqués sont terribles selon les
chiffres de l'étude OBP roche donc 32,3
% des adultes sont en surpoids en France
contre près de 40 % en outrem 15 % sont
considérés comme obèse en France mais ce
chiffre est de 30 % en outrem pour les
enfants ces chiffres sont inférieurs à 5
% mais plus de 8 % en Outremer ces
chiffres confirmés par d'autres études
qui démontrent elles aussi le que le
surpoids et l'obésité sont
significativement plus élevé chez les
femmes par ailleurs outre M la
prévalence de l'obésité et des autres
pathologies associées diabète
hypertension artérielle maladie
cardiovasculaire et plus élevé qu'en
métropole l'État a tenté de prendre
quelques mesures notamment dans le plan
obésité
2010-23 ou encore le Programme National
Nutrition Santé
2011-2015 en direction des populations
d'outrem vous en avez parlé monsieur le
rapporteur parmi les mesures préconisé
dans ce programme l'une disait je cite
faire en sorte que pour une gamme
comparable de produits la teneur moyenne
en sucre soit identique dans les
territoires des départements d'outrem et
en méop po cela mettait en évidence la
responsabilité des industriels de
l'agroalimentaire dans la progression de
l'obésité hélas rien n'indique
aujourd'hui que cette mesure a été prise
en compte d'ailleurs monsieur le
ministre vous le rappeliez à l'instant
rien n'a été fait notamment depuis la
discussion à l'Assemblée nationale de la
présente de de ce présent texte et ce ne
sont pas seulement les producteurs
ultramarins qui sont visés mais aussi
les fabricants de l'Hexagone qui pour
leur production destinée à l'outrem
augmentent les taux de sucre ainsi un
même produit d'une même marque comporte
donc plus de sucre s'il est destiné à la
Réunion à la Martinique à la Guyane ou à
la Guadeloupe que s'il était vendu à
Strasbourg ou à Toulouse ou à Grenoble
pour citer mon département une
différence qui peut aller jusqu'à 50 %
au nom de quoi d'une supposée appétence
des populations d'outrem pour le sucre
l'argument est complètement faux il est
même méprisant pour les populations
d'outrem puisque en réalité ils n'ont
pas vraiment le choix puisque tout est
sucré parmi les produits de consommation
en outrem et il n'est pas non plus
possible de cautionner l'explication
avancée dans l'introduction du Programme
national nutrition santé je cite la
spécificité de la situation alimentaire
en outre mer est étroitement liée aux
particularités culturel et économique
mais aussi aux particularités
géographiques et climatiques donc aux
productions agricoes ainsi au prétexte
que l'Outremer produit du sucre les
populations d'outremer devraient
consommer plus de sucre on peut en
revanche s'arrêter aussi sur les mots
particularités économiques de l'outrem
un rapport de l'Agence Française de
Développement laafd a mis l'accent sur
l'indice de développement humain dans
tous les outremèes cet indicateur prend
en compte des données de 2010 relatives
à l'éducation au revenus mais aussi à la
santé en les comparant aux résultats
enregistrés dans l'exagone force est de
constater que les retards sont flagrants
20 ans en moyenne la Réunion accuse un
retard de 25 ans pour la Guadeloupe
c'est 12 ans mais pour la Polynésie
c'est 28 ans bien évidemment cela se
traduit aussi dans le produit intérieur
brut en moyenne pour l'année 2009 les
PIB pour les départements d'outremer
sont inférieurs de 60
% à la moyenne des PIB de l'Union
européenne le contexte socio-économique
est donc extrêmement difficile la
question du coût de la vie et du pouvoir
d'achat est particulièrement importante
il y a quelques jours comme l'avait fait
déjà les anti et la Réunion il y a
quelques mois les Calédoniens sont
descendus dans la rue pour manifester
contre la vie chère dans l'Outremer une
grande partie de la population vit avec
un pouvoir d'achat moindre alors que le
coût de la vie y est nettement supérieur
à la moyenne nationale il y a là une
inégalité inacceptable mais cette
inégalité entraîne une autre inégalité
tout aussi inacceptable en effet une
analyse a montré que plus le niveau de
revenus était élevé moins la prévalence
de la surcharge pondérale était
importante et donc par voie de
conséquence malheureusement plus le
pouvoir d'achat est faible et plus la
prévalence de l'obésité est importante
car les familles les plus modestes
hésitent à se faire soigner mais en plus
elles ne peuvent acheter uniquement pour
des raisons financières des produits
alimentaires dit sains troème injustice
inacceptable la question des dates
limites de consommation comment peut-on
justifier que certains produits
périssables comme les yaourts est outre
M une date de péremption plus longue
qu'un produit identique de même marque
vendu en France cet écart peut atteindre
25 jours c'est cette inégalité je dois
le dire mes chers collègues monsieur le
ministre qui m'a le plus étonné dans ce
texte car il n'y a il n'y a vraiment
aucune raison à à cette différence de de
date et vous citiez monsieur le ministre
le reblochon alors là pour le coup je ne
vois vraiment pas comment on peut donner
une date de péremption différente cette
loi va donc permettre de supprimer non
seulement quelques injustices mais
également des des inégalités et c'est
cela le plus important néanmoins il
reste encore beaucoup à faire pour faire
reculer le surpoids et l'obésité et
ainsi réduire les risques de maladies
cardio-vasculaires il conviendrait par
exemple de prendre les dispositions
nécessaires pour que les préconisations
du Programme national nutrition santé
soit enfin prise en compte celui-ci
proposait par ailleurs d'agir sur
l'offre alimentaire en milieux scolaire
de valoriser les ressources et la
production agroalimentaire locale ou
encore d'agir sur le dispositif d'aide
alimentaire c'est donc bien la question
de l'approvisionnement des marchés qui
se posent et c'est dans dans son article
4 que cette proposition de loi vise à
promouvoir les denrées issues des
circuits courts de distribution afin de
favoriser l'approvisionnement des sites
de restauration collective en produits
frais et de saison l'intention est
louable et on ne peut qu'y adhérer mais
faut-il le rappeler les lois comme le
Grenel 1 ou la loi de modernisation
agricole envisageaient dà déjà cette
possibilité or comme souvent les
dispositions n'ont jamais été prises
concernant l'outrem afin deend en compte
leur spécificité à savoir les critères
d'étroitesse des marchés locaux ou
l'éloignement de ce qui est appelé les
grands marchés et qui sont ceux histoire
oblige de France ou d'Europe comme nous
l'a souvent expliqué mon collègue le
sénateur Paul vergess mon collègue et
ami cette situation de dépendance
économique est la traduction d'un
développement qui s'est toujours fait
dans le même sens les anciennes colonies
avec la mère patrie puis l'Europe et
derrière cela c'est la question des
accords de partenariat économique bien
évidemment il s'agit avant tout de
promouvoir la production locale cette
production locale doit être non
seulement préservée mais également
renforcée pour soutenir des prix
supportable dans l'intérêt des
consommateurs mais on ne peut occulter
la question de la diversification des
sources d'approvisionnement et cela doit
se traduire par la prise en compte de la
situation spécifique de la Réunion et
des autres département d'outreemère dans
le cadre des accords de partenariat
économique c'est un chantier qui reste
encore à poursuivre et nous comptons
monsieur le ministre avec mon groupe sur
votre action ferme et déterminée pour
faire valoir ses spécificités mais pour
l'heure il est question de cette
proposition de loi sur l'offre
alimentaire et avec le groupe communiste
républicain et citoyens nous le voterons
je vous
remerci merci madame la Présidente la
parole est à Monsieur Joë guerot pour le
groupe udi
UC monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues l'objet
principale de la présente proposition de
loi est de s'attaquer à deux problèmes
affectant la qualité de l'offre
alimentaire
ultramarine celui de la teneur en sucre
ajouté de certains produits et celui des
dates limites de consommation parfois
différencié pour les territoires
ultramarin plus précisément le texte
vise d'une part à fixer une teneur
maximale en sucre ajouté par les
produits alimentaires distribués dans
les outremers et d'autre part à disposer
que le délai limite de consommation ne
peut être plus long pour les produits
destinés à l'outrem que celui prévu pour
la même donrée alimentaire distribuée
dans l'Hexagone le constat bien sûr nous
le partageons concernant la tenue la
teneur en sucre des boissons sucrées et
des yaourt il est totalement anormal
qu'elle puisse être supérieure en outre
mer que dans l'Hexagone les chiffres
dont nous a fait part notre rapporteur
sont édifiants jusqu'à 47 % d'écart
entre la teneur en glucide de boisson
sucré distribué localement et dans
l'Hexagone l'allégation par les
industriels d'une prétendeux préférence
locale pour le sucre laisse sans voie de
deux choses l'une soit effectivement
cette préférence est culturelle mais
alors elle ne doit pas être entretenue
pour des raisons évidentes de santé
publique soit au contraire est fictive
et cela se justif bien se justifie
encore moins sauf à s'interroger sur sa
motivation réelle ce qui m'amène à la
seconde question celle des dates limites
de consommation même constat et même
réaction qu'il puisse y avoir des dates
limites de consommation selon le produit
est destiné au marché hexagonal ou au
marché ultramarin est totalement
injustifiable et totalement
aberrant une parfaite illustration de
l'anecdote que nous comptait il y a peu
de temps la garde des saut certains sur
ces bans s'en souviendront peut-être qui
en arrivant en France n'a pas retrouvver
dans l'Hexagone le gruyère de son
enfance en effet nous disait-elle le
gruyère de son enfance picotait alors
plaisanterie à part encore une fois les
chiffres de notre rapporteur sont
édifiants 55 jours de délai de
préemption péremption affiché pour la
consommation d'un produit outremer quand
il n'est que de 30 en France c'est tout
bonne
invraisemblable nous rejoignons votre
raisonnement implacable monsieur le
rapporteur contenu des conditions de
transport les 10 produits il s'il y
avait une date limite de consommation
différencié il devrait être avancé et
non reculé il faudrait peut-être
faudraitil reculer toutes les dates de
préemption y compris sur l'Hexagone à
moins que les produits en question
contiennent davantage de
conservateurs vous l'aurez compris mes
chers collègues pour nous la question du
sucre et celles des dates de péremption
sont liées on le sait le le sucre
conserve il est donc probable que l'une
des raisons à l'intensification en sucre
de certaines dorées microbiologiquement
instabl typiquement les yaourts soit de
leur permettre de durer plus longtemps
ce qui bien sûr n'excuse en rien cette
mesure et doit être combatue parce que
c'est de la santé des ultramarins dont
il est question et encore une fois nous
partageons le constat fait sur le
surpoid sur l'obésité sur le diabète tel
que ça a été rappelé par ma collègue
précédente ces ces affections sont
particulièrement prévalentes en outreem
il n'est pas normal et encore moins
acceptable que l'obésité il soit de 23 %
contre 14,5 % dans l'Hexagone soit et
parfois même de trois fois plus en
Guadeloupe et en Martinique enen
métropole
idem pour le diabète dont le taux de
prévalence à la Réunion est le double de
celui de l'Hexagone évidemment ces
pathologies ont de multiples causes mais
le lien avec la surconsommation de sucre
est bien établi si donc nous partageons
le constat global fait par les auteurs
de la proposition en revanche nous
différons quant aux solutions apportter
au problème primo je voudrais sans Malis
faire observer qu'il y a comme aatus
entre l'intitulé du texte et son contenu
véritable lorsqu'il ne s'agit que de
légiférer sur le taux de sucre et la
date de péremption de certains produits
on ne peut pas dire que l'on garantit
globalement la qualité de l'offre
alimentaire en outreem c'est bien sûr
ambitieux comme
intitulé sauf à considérer que l'outrem
n'a vraiment aucun autre problème quant
à la qualité de son offre alimentaire ce
qui chacun le sait est loin d'être le
cas second dos est plus fondamentalement
nous ne pensons pas qu'en l'occurrence
le recours à la loi se justifie à tout
le moins pas une proposition de loi
aussi circonstancier encore une fois de
deux choses l'unes soit il n'est
effectivement question que de traiter du
taux de sucre et de la date de
péremption de certains produits il ne
revient pas à la loi de le faire soit au
contraire on entend traiter globalement
les problèmes d'alimentation et de santé
publique et c'est d'un texte d'une
envergure plus grande dont nous aurions
aimé être saisis je reviens à la
première branche de l'alternative les
seules questions du taux de sucre et de
la date de péremption ne relèvent pas de
la loi le rapporteur lui-même l'a dit la
question relève de divers plans et
programmes le Programme national
nutrition santé ainsi que le plan
obésité qui ont fait l'objet de
déclinaison spécifiqu pour l'outrem
ainsi que le programme national pour
l'alimentation autrement dit la
proposition de loi qui nous est soumise
est strictement de nature réglementaire
en revanche qu'il faille une grande loi
de santé publique qui revoit toutes les
questions se posant à la matière oui
nous l'appelons fortement de nous veux
la dernière date de 2004 depuis les
choses ont bien sûr évolué les sujets
sont nombreux de la fiscalité
comportementale à l'éducation à la santé
en passant par la problématique des
allicaments cette loi nous a été
annoncée à plusieurs reprises mais nous
ne la voyons pas venir monsieur le
ministre pourez-vous nous en dire
quelques mots à ce à ce sujet en
attendant cette grande loi de santé
publique nous ne pouvons que regretter
une fois de plus que les questions
ultramarines ne soitent pas traité dans
leur globalité c'était déjà le cas de
mon intervention lors de la proposition
de loi prorogeant le bonus exceptionnel
outremaire en même temps que nous
appelons de nouveau une grande loi de
santé publique nous réclamons aussi de
véritables réformes qui marqueraient un
être progrès pour les collectivités
ultramarines merci de votre
attention merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Claude
reéquier pour le groupe
RDSE monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues la qualité de
l'alimentation devrait être un droit
imprescriptible de chaque citoyen et
citoyens notre autre assemblée a adopté
la semaine dernière une proposition de
résolution européenne de nos collègues
du groupe udiuc tendant à la création
d'un droit européen pour le consommateur
à la maîtrise et la connaissance
parfaite son alimentation qui touche
aussi à cette problématique au combien
essentielle
de ce point de vue l'injustice dont
souffrent les populations ultramarines
qui du fait d'industriel peu scrupuleux
consomme des produits souvent beaucoup
plus sucrés que ce vendu en métropole et
dans la date de consommation est
repoussé parfois jusqu'à 25 jours par
rapport à ces derniers est
incompréhensible elle est
intolérable la présente proposition de
loi et dans un texte de bon sens il n'y
a aucune raison pour qu'un produit et un
taux de sucre
ajouté beaucoup plus élevé parfois
jusqu'à 50 % quand il est destiné au
consommateurs ultramarin l'obésité et le
surpoids qui peuvent avoir des
conséquences dramatiques que nous
connaissons sur la santé touch très
durement les populations ultramarines en
mettant fin à cette pratique commerciale
injustifiable qui consiste à sucré
davantage car le sucre est moins cher
les produits vendus en outreem cette
proposition de loi contribuera à la
réduction de ce fléo certes la réduction
du taux de sucre dans les yaourts ou les
sodas ne résoudra pas à elle seule la
question de l'obésité et des risques
pour la santé qui en découle diabète
hypertension accidents cardio-vasculaire
il faudra également renforcer la
prévention et l'éducation alimentaire le
ministre délégué chargé de
l'agroalimentaire a également annoncé
qu'il avait engagé une concertation avec
les industries
pour pouvoir améliorer la composition de
certains ingrédients alimentaires et
revoir leur teneur en sucre sel et
graisse j'espire j'espère vivement que
cette démarche aboutira rapidement et
contribuera à renforcer la prise en
compte de la santé des consommateurs de
plus s' est utile à mon avis de recourir
au véhicules législatif pour encadrer la
qualité de l'alimentation il est
également indispensable de s'assurer que
les règles que nous votons seront
respectés et que les contrôles et
sanctions seront adoptés l'expérience a
montré que nous ne pouvions pas nous
reposer sur les chartes de bonne
conduite de la part des industries
agro-alimentaires il y a déjà eu une
bonne trentaine et le moins qu'on puisse
dire est que leur efficacité pour la
protection des consommateurs et la santé
s'est avéré très
limitée la présente proposition de loi
prévoit que les manquements constatés
aux nouvelles obligations concernant la
les différences des taux de sucre dans
les produits vendus en France
métropolitaine et en outrem sont
constatés par les agents de la Direction
générale de la concurrence de la
consommation et de la répression des
fraudes mais encore faut-il et cette
question se pose sur l'ensemble du
territoire français encore faut-il que
la DGCCRF et les moyens humains et
financiers d'effectuer tous les
contrôles qui sont de son ressort ces
missions sont de plus en plus vastes à
l'effet les types de froid de plus en
plus varié et évolue de plus en plus
vite mais pendant ce temps les moyens de
la DGCCRF sont en chute libre notre
collègue Robert Riano a déjà dénoncé ici
ce phénomène dans une question
d'actualité il y a quelques semaines
mais c'est un enjeu majeur nous ne
pourrons garantir la qualité de notre
alimentation si l'effectivité de
contrôle et des sanctions contre les
abus n'est pas assurée le projet de loi
relatif à la consommation que nous
examinerons dans les prochains mois pose
les mêmes question question il renforce
les sanctions contre les différents
types de fraude à l'encontre des droits
des consommateurs et élargit les
pouvoirs de la des gccrf mais la
question des moyens cette administration
est encore en suspent or nous devons à
nos concitoyens de donner ces moyens à
cette direction pour qu'elle puisse
efficacement protéger les consommateurs
et leur santé je referme cette
parenthèse pour revenir à la proposition
de loi sur la qualité de l'offre
alimentaire outre mè ne concernant
l'origine que l'interdiction de la
différence de taux de sucre entre la
composition des produits manufacturés et
vendu dans les régions d'outrem et les
mêmes produits dans l'Hexagone cette
proposition de loi a été également a été
utilement précisée et complétée à
l'Assemblée nationale outre l'article 1
et 2 qui concerne le sucre l'article 3
concerne les dates limites de
consommation la pratique de certains
industriels qui consiste à poser une
date limite de consommation différente
pour les produits fabriqué en France
hexagonale selon que ce ceuxci son
destiné au marché hexagonal ou au marché
ultramarin n'est pas plus acceptable que
celle qui consiste à ajouter davantage
de sucre cette pratique montre combien
la notion d'information et de protection
du consommateur peut-être manipulé ainsi
les consommateurs métropolitains jettent
des produits périmés entre guillemets
alors que ces mêmes produits sont
considérés comme encore consommables à
notre mè or selon la directive EUR
euréne concernant l'étiquetage et la
présentation des Darré alimentaires de
de 2010 pour les darr
microbiologiquement très périssabl comme
les yaourt au-delà de la date limite de
consommation une darrée alimentaire est
d dangereuse par conséquent comment nous
assurer que cet allongement de la date
limite de consommation par rapport au
produits vendus en métropole ne présente
aucun risque en matière de santé pour
les consommateurs ultramarins il me
semble qu'il faudrait mettre cette
question des dates de préremption des
alimentaire sur la table c'est dire au
niveau européen en effet les fabricants
sont libres de fixer ces dates dans la
mesure où respecte un certain nombre de
garanties sanitaires mais force de
constater que ces dates ne permettent
pas d'assurer une bonne information du
consommateur à l'heure actuelle d'une
manière générale la transparence de
l'étiquetage et la traçabilité des Arrs
alimentaires doit être renforcé la
législation européenne actuelle sur ces
points compte trop de failles je vous
renvoie discussion que nous avons eu
mercredi dernier lors de l'examen de la
proposition de résolution de nos
collègue du groupe udi et UC dont j'ai
parlé à l'introduction j'espère que
cette résolution portera rapidement ses
fruits et que les avancées
significatives seront rapporté sera acté
prochainement au niveau communautaire
enfin la rapporteur de la commission de
de proposition de loi à l'Assemblée
national a également fait adopter un 4e
article qui vise à à promouvoir voir
l'approvisionnement des sites de
restauration collective cantines
hôpitaux par des circuit cours de
distribution ira obligatoire pour
l'attribution des marchés publics de
resturation collective la prise en
compte du critère de performance en
matière de développement des
approvisionnement direct en produit de
l'agriculture c'est un apport majeur
puisque les outremèes ont souvent des
productions locales de fruits et de
légumes importantes et diversifié mais
qu'une part très faible seulement est
consommée sur les lieux de restauration
collective un seul chiffre un seul 8 %
des 90000 tonnes des de fruits et
légumes produit à la Réunion chaque
année sont consommés dans les écoles et
les hôpitaux de Lille ce dispositif est
donc essentiel et mériterait
probablement d'être étendu à la pêche et
à l'aquaculture ce 4e article de la
proposition de loi contribuera donc à
garantir une offre
alimentaire de qualité dans les lieux de
restauration collective et en
particulier à l'école pour les enfants
tout en favorisant les producteurs
locaux je rappelle Simp simplement que
seul 1/3 des établisss scolaires de
Guyane dispose d'une cantine or la
nécessité de disposer de tes
infrastructures est une priorité avant
de pouvoir garantir l'accueil et
l'alimentation saine des enfants quoi
qu'il en soit l'article 4 de la
proposition de loi en favorisant les
circuits court permet à la fois de
protéger la santé de nos concitoyens de
dynamiser le tissu économique local et
de réduire l'impact environnemental lié
au transport de marchandis c'est donc
une mesure de bon sens aussi bien pour
les territoires ultrarin que pour le
territoire de l'hexagone et j'espère
vivement que d'autres textes
s'inpireront pour conclure cette
proposition de loi qui répond à des
exigences de justice d'équité et de
santé publique mérite un soutien unanime
de tous les parlementaire qui soit
d'outrem ou de métropole tous nos
concitoyens en saisissent l'importance
les en jeu c'est pour ça que l'ensemble
des membres du groupe RDSE votera pour
cette proposition de
loi merci Monsieur requier la parole est
à madame Aline archimbaau pour le groupe
écologie monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
la question de la surconsommation de
sucre est un grave sujet de santé
publique de nombreux collègues l'ont dit
avant moi dans ce débat et notre groupe
écologiste se réjouit que par cette
proposition de loi on ait pris
l'initiative de le mettre à l'agenda à
chaque fois que l'occasion nous en est
donnée et notamment à chaque projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale nous rappelons l'idée que la
santé publique ne doit pas être abordée
simplement sous l'angle curatif mais
doit aussi s'inscrire dans une démarche
constante de prévention et de promotion
de la santé publique c'est l'option qui
est retenue ici et nous nous en
félicitons par ailleurs le texte
s'inscrit dans une seconde logique celle
de la lutte contre les inégalités qui
frappe les consommateurs ultramarins par
rapport au consommateurs de la France
hexagonale comment concevoir en
effet qu'en nreemè
les produits de consommation courante et
une concentration en sucre supérieure à
celle des mêmes produits de même marque
vendu en France hexagonale pour prendre
un exemple un autre exemple le Fanta
orange le soda Fanta orange acheté à
Paris comporte
9,446 g de sucre pour 100 g
et le même produit pour 100 g le même
soda acheté en Guadeloupe comporte plus
de sucre plus 48 % en Guyane plus 45 %
en Martinique plus 42 % à Mayotte et
ainsi de suite c'est une pratique
inadmissible qu'aucun argument objectif
ne justifie et qui a des effets directs
sur la santé des populations puisque
cela a déjà été dit je le répète les
sucres sont une des causes principales
personne ne le conteste de l'épidémie
d'obésité qui jusqu'ici pas été
suffisamment traité en outreem 25 % des
enfants et adolescents et plus d'un
adulte sur deux sont en effet touchés
par des problèmes de surcharge pondérale
or l'obésité favorise en effet la
survenue de diabète hypertension maladie
cardio-ovasculairire respiratoire et
atteinte articulaire source de handicap
l'enjeu sur le plan sanitaire est donc
extrêmement important notre groupe avait
d'ailleurs déposé déjà au moment de
l'examen du projet de loi V ch en
outreem à l'automne dernier un
amendement correspondant au contenu de
l'article 1 de cette proposition de loi
que nous soutiendrons bien sûr à nouveau
aujourd'hui concernant cet article
premier une seule chose nous préoccupe
le fait que ce soit un arrêté
ministériel qui doivent déterminer je
cite la liste des denrées alimentaires
concernées car si l'article 2 précise
bien que je cite l'article 1er entre en
vigueur dans un délai de 6 mois à compé
de la promulgation de la présente loi le
risque est que la publication de cet
arrêté provoque une certaine inertie
d'ailleurs un arrêté était-il bien
nécessaire puisque tous les produits
contenant du sucre sont concernés de
plus le fait que cet arrêté relève de
quatre ministères trois autres ministère
à part le ministère des de
l'outreem n'est pas rassurant quant à
l'objectif de l'effectivité rapide de
cette mesure et nous comptons sur vous
monsieur le ministre pour vous assurer
que la concertation la prise de décision
entre les quatre ministères se fasse
aussi vite que possible comp comptez
également sur notre grande vigilance à
ce sujet outre ces dispositions
relatives au taux de sucre le groupe
écologiste se se félicite également des
deux autres articles additionnels dont
la première lecture par nos collègues
députés est venu enrichir le texte
concernant les dates de consommation
recommandées tout d'abord en effet de
deux choses l'une soit les dates
pratiquées en France hexagonale sont
justes et il n'y a dans ce cas aucune
raison que les consommateurs ultramarins
se voient pratiquer des délais de
consommation recommandé supérieur soit
les dates pratiquées en France sont
largement sous-estimés et on pourrait
voir une volonté inadmissible de pousser
les ménages à la consommation en leur
faisant jeter gaspiller des des aliments
encore propres à la consommation pour en
acheter de nouveau dans les deux cas il
y a une situation à éclaircir qui n'est
pas qui n'est pas acceptable enfin
concernant le développement des
approvisionnements directs de de
produits de l'agriculture locale
notamment par le biais des marchés
publics de restauration collective nous
nous félicitons de cette juste mesure
qui sera en encourageant les circuits
courts à la fois source de création
d'emplois locaux non délocalisables
renforcera l'indépendance économique
l'autosuffisance alimentaire des
territoires ultramarins et sera même un
outil de lutte contre la vie chère en
conclusion le double enjeu 200 santé
publique et d'égalité des territoires
vous avez employé à juste titre monsieur
le ministre l'expression lutte contre
les
discriminations cet enjeu dont nous
débattons aujourd'hui est tel que
l'action réglementaire n'aurait pas
suffi étant donné les les résistances
les longs délais dans lesquels devant
lesquels nous sommes à propos de de C de
ce projet depuis des années c'est bel et
bien d'un débat public et d'un vote du
Parlement dont nous avons besoin qui
manifeste la volonté d'une décision
énergique dont encore une fois nous
avons besoin par ailleurs nous sommes
certes nous aussi écologistes pour une
grande loi de santé publique qui régule
notamment entre autres les questions de
sécurité alimentaire mais demander au
nom de cette future grande loi que l'on
renonce aujourd'hui à cette proposition
de loi nous paraît une mauvaise idée
peut-être même de mauvaise foi et nous
ne voyons pas encore une fois qu'il soit
possible de différer et de renvoyer à
plus tard la décision pour toutes ces
raisons notre groupe votera pour cette
proposition de loi en état et nous
espérons encore une fois qu'elle pourra
entrer en vigueur rapidement je vous
remercie merci Madame archinbaau la
parole est à Monsieur Alain Milan pour
le groupe
UMP
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la Présidente de la
Commission des affffaires sociales
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues la proposition de loi que nous
examinons aujourd'hui pose une vraie
question de santé publique la lutte
contre l'obésité est un enjeu majeur
pour tous les Français dans les agone
comme outrem vous connaissez les
chiffres ils ont été rappelés plusieurs
fois de la dernière enquête
épidémiologique nationale sur le
surpoids et l'obésité près de 7 millions
de Français seraient considérés comme
obèses soit le double d'il y a 15 ans
ces données sont évidemment inquiétantes
et la situation dans les territoires
ultramarin est encore plus grave comme
le disait tout à l'heure monsieur le
rapporteur
l'obésité qui est nous le savons un
problème
comportemental touche en effet 15 à 20 %
de la population adulte de la Guadeloupe
de la Réunion et de la Martinique
l'obésité concerne 10,5 % des enfants
des quatre départements d'outremer
contre 3 % des enfants en métropole
cette différence est évidemment
inacceptable au total sur ces
territoires près d'un/4 des enfants et
adolescents et plus de la moitié des
adultes sont touchés par des problèmes
de surcharge pondérale et nous savons
bien que l'obésité constitue un facteur
de risque aggravant pour le
développement de maladies comme le
diabète comme l'hypertension artérielle
comme les maladies coronariennes ce
texte repose donc sur un diagnostic que
nous partageons tous sur tous les bancs
vous avez raison monsieur le rapporteur
lorsque vous dites que la situation en
outrem exige une mobilisation renforcée
des autorités sanitaires et des
professionnels de l'alimentation il faut
améliorer la qualité nutritionnelle de
l'offre alimentaire et encourager nos
concitoyens à adopter des comportements
alimentaires plus favorables à leur
santé je rappelle qu'une alimentation
équilibrée associée à une activité
physique permet une meilleure prévention
de maladies cardiovasculaires du diabète
de l'obésité elle-même et des cancers il
est donc nécessaire de promouvoir de
saines pratiques alimentaires il existe
d'ors et déjà des outils pour lutter
contre
l'obésité avec la 3e édition je rappelle
que la première date de 2001 du
Programme national nutrition santé pour
les années 2011 à 2015 not notre pays
s'est doté d'une politique
nutritionnelle ambitieuse afin
d'améliorer l'état de santé de nos
concitoyen ce programme comprend une
déclinaison spécifique à l'outr-em ainsi
qu'un plan obésité le secteur de
l'alimentation a d'ors et déjà fait des
efforts selon le site du ministère de la
Santé 33 chartes d'engagement volontaire
de progrès nutritionnel ont été signé
par des centaines d'entreprises alors
même qu'il n'existe pas d'obligation
réglementaire fixant la teneur en CRE
des produits par ailleurs un programme
national de l'alimentation a été mis en
place en 2010 pour inciter les
opérateurs du secteur
agroalimentaire à mettre en œuvre des
accords collectifs par famille de
produits avec des objectifs en matière
de qualité
nutritionnelle pouvez-vous d'ailleurs
monsieur le ministre nous préciser les
avancées obtenues depuis la mise en
place de ces programmes nationaux j'en
viens aux dispositions de la proposition
de loi le premier objectif de ce texte
est d'éviter qu'un produit de même
marque soit plus sucré outre mer qu'en
métropole les produits concernés ser
notamment les yaourts les sodas les jus
de fruits et cetera
si nous sommes totalement d'accord pour
supprimer cette différence nous voulons
souligner le risque de distorsion de
concurrence entre les entreprises
françaises et celles d'autres pays
notamment les États-Unis en particulier
aux antillle qui pourrait exister il est
donc essentiel tant d'un point de vue
sanitaire que d'un point de vue
économique de renforcer la promotion des
comportements alimentaires plus
favorables à la santé
le deuxième objectif de ce texte est
d'interdire la fixation pour une denrée
alimentaire distribuée en autreomère
d'une date limite de consommation
emportant un délai de consommation plus
long que le délai prévu pour la même
durée de même marque pour les mêmes
denrées de même marque distribué dans
l'Hexagone nous nous réjouissons que des
solutions soient rechercher pour
remédier à cette situation monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous nous indiquer
ce que compte faire le gouvernement pour
empêcher que les entreprises européennes
non françaises ne contournent cette
disposition afin de conserver des dates
limites de consommation
différentes le troisème et dernier
objectif de ce texte est la promotion de
l'agriculture locale pour louable que
soi ces objectifs ils ne correspondent
pas réellement à la lutte contre
l'obésité
régulièrement le gouvernement annonce
le dépôt d'un projet de loi de santé
publique ce texte sera un véhicule
législatif approprié pour prendre en
compte de manière beaucoup plus globale
les problèmes liés à la prévalence de
l'obésité et à ses conséquences sur les
populations il ne pourra d'ailleurs s'y
limiter il devra aussi traiter les
questions relative aux addictions
notamment chez les jeunes l'annonce de
cette nouvelle loi de santé publique où
ouvre par ailleurs la possibilité de
donner une nouvelle imposion de à la
politique de lutte contre les troubles
mentaux pour conclure mes chers
collègues même si ce texte part d'une
bonne intention il nous semble à minima
pour atteindre les objectifs qu'il
affiche c'est pourquoi une grande partie
du groupe UMP s'abstiendra sur
celui-ci merci Monsieur Milan la parole
est à Monsieur T Mohamed de sol pour le
groupe
socialiste monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers
collègues notre assemblée est appelée
aujourd'hui à examiner une proposition
de loi visant à mettre fin à une
situation discriminatoire et injustifiée
dans nos territoires d'outrem certains
produits alimentaires comme les soda ou
les yaourts contiennent bien plus de
sucre que leurs équivalents vendus en
métropole aucun impératif de
conservation ne saurait être invoqué
pour justifier cet état de fait sinon
pour quel raison les délais de
péremption d'un produit alimentaire
seraent-il plus long en autre mer que
partout ailleurs sur le territoire il y
a aussi cette prétendue appétence pour
le sucre des ultramarins avancé par les
industriels qui n'est fondé sur aucune
étude scientifique et ne saurait donc
constituer un argument valable comme
chacun sa le sucre appelle le sucre
consommé régulièrement il peut même
devenir une véritable addiction on sait
aujourd'hui que cette différence de
traitement qui avait déjà fait l'objet
d'une proposition de loi en 2011 rejetée
par la précédente majorité et en partie
responsable du surpoids de l'obésité
mais aussi des pathologies graves
associées telles que le diabète
l'hypertension artérielle ou encore de
maladies cardiovasculaires qui touchent
aujourd'hui plus durement les
ultramarins que les
hexagonaux certes l'obésité ne trouve
pas son origine dans la seule teneur
élevée en sucre dans l'alimentation
plusieurs facteurs rentrent en ligne de
compte mais donner aux populations
ultramarines la possibilité de choisir
de mieux se nourrir est essentielle il y
a encore 5 ans faute d'enquête
spécifique la situation du diabète à
Mayotte n'était pas connue la première
grande étude trans de la population
réalisée en 2008 afin d'estimer la
prévalence du diabète et des facteurs de
risque cardiovasculaire a révélé que 35
% des hommes et 32 % des femmes étaient
en surpoids et que l'obésité touchait 17
% des hommes et 47 % des femmes la
prévalence du diabète s'élevait à 10,5 %
alors qu'elle était de 4,9 % en France
métropolitaine
chez les plus de 30 ans une personne sur
10 était atteinte chez les plus de 60
ans une personne sur 5 et plus d'une
personne sur deux ignorit qu'elle était
diabétique l'émergence de ces nouvelles
maladies du moins à Mayotte a
correspondu avec la transition
socio-économique à laquelle cette île a
fait face ces dernières
années certaines organisations telles
que la Jid 96 16 aide aux jeunes
diabétiques 976 hidab bilang 976 dont je
tiens ici à saluer le travail relaye les
campagnes nationales et joue un rôle
essentiel en matière d'éducation
thérapeutique du patient il faut bien
évidemment encourager et davantage aider
ces
organisations en alignant le taux de
sucre entre les outromèes et l'Hexagone
cette proposition de loi ne réclame rien
de moins que le rétablissement de
l'égalité les inégalités territoriales
de santé sont particulièrement
importantes entre nos territoires et la
métropole ce texte a le mérite de mettre
un terme à l'une
d'elles il est également l'occasion de
rappeler les bienfaits d'une
alimentation saine et équilibrée et
d'insister sur l'importance des
campagnes d'information et de
sensibilisation notamment dans les
écoles ce texte répond enfin à la 11e
des 30 propositions faites par François
Hollande en faveur des autres maires
lors de sa campagne électorale je vous
mercie merci mon cher collègue la parole
est à Monsieur Félix des plans pour le
groupe
socialiste
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues le sucre a écrit les premières
pages
de l'histoire de la
Guadeloupe plus de 3 siècles après il
nous réunit pour mettre fin à une autre
injustice celle de de l'inégalité entre
consommateurs les ultrarins n'ont pas le
droit à la même qualité alimentaire et
cela n'est pas juste cette proposition
de loi rétablit donc
l'égalité face à des disparités
discriminatoires
expliqué par des prétextes
fallacieux nous avons tous sans
exception une appétence innée pour le
sucre carburant indispensable il est à
la fois le meilleur et le pire de nos
aliments sa carence ou son absence nous
est
fatale mais son excès qui est de nos
jours beaucoup plus courant est tout
aussi
dangereux aujourd'hui la consommation de
sucre comportement ubiquitaire des
sociétés
industrialisé dépasse des niveaux plus
que
nécessaires pourquoi celle des des
ultrarin devrait-elle être plus
importante doit-on laisser notre destin
aux mains de la dictature du sucre
raffiné doit-on laisser à nouveau
s'orchestrer un crime
organisé basé sur le commerce du sucre
ce doux poison ce doux
assassin dans le cadre du projet
guadeloupéen de société nous élu réunis
en Congrès le 21 décembre 2013 sur la
thématique santé et alimentation avions
déjà conscience de l'état de santé
édifiant des
Guadeloupéens afin de faire évoluer les
PR alimentaires la nécessité de mener
des politiques publiques d'établir des
PL d'action c'est peu à peu imposé dans
nos
agendas parce qu'une mauvaise
alimentation tue bien plus de personnes
chaque année que les drogues notre
consommation de certains aliments est
telle qu'elle s'apparente à une
addiction à des drogue
dur disons-le nous le sucre est bel et
bien une drogue
contemporaine il participe CER
directement à l'apparition de plusieurs
maladies et problèm de santé obésité
diabète et d'autres qui on été cités
mais non content de causer des dégâts
durable sur notre santé physique il
fragilise notre équilibre
mental un nombre croissant de recherche
scientifique démontre qu'en
surconsommation il peut influencer
l'humeur et les comportements humains
dont
l'agressivité la
violence en effet une
hypoglycémie favorise l'irritabilité et
l'agression
impulsive ces études sont principalement
d'Origin étrangères je le conçois mais
doit-on attendre des confirmation en
France avant
d'agir peut-on rester les bras croisés
les mots dont souffre ce bout de terre
qui met cher sont suffisants en nombre
la violence et les sécurité qui la
malmène sont l'expression de pathologie
sociétale sil est des facteur exogène
qui laarronge de l'Intérieur en
provenance de nos assiettes il est de
notre devoir de les
éliminer le président de la République a
porté lors de sa campagne cette grande
idée d'égalité des
territoires lors de la conférence de
presse du 16 mai il a à nouveau rappeler
cette ligne de conduite je le cite je
fais en sorte que là où il y a plus
d'inégalité nous fassions
davantage la promesse de de l'égalité ce
n'est pas une nostalgie ça reste une
ambition cette valeur est une part de
notre identité
cette promesse s laquelle la France
s'est historiquement construite et à
laquelle nous devons d'être
fidèle donnonsnous l'ambition de la
tenir en commençant par réconcilier tous
ceux qui font la
France traduisons en acte dès
aujourd'hui cette belle idée d'égalité
ce droit intangible en réalité concrète
pour les
ultramarins je vai donc cette
proposition de loi engagement du C de
campagne de François Hollande pour
l'utre meilleur je vous
remercie merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur mauriisantiste
pour le groupe
socialiste
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la Présidente de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues depuis plusieurs années
on assiste en France hexagonale et dans
les collectivités d'outrem à une
augmentation de la prévalence du su au
poids de l'obésité et du diabète type 2
cette augmentation a une origine
multifactorielle comme le patrimoine
génétique la trop faible activité
physique quotidienne ou encore le
déséquilibre alimentaire cependant pour
les ultramarins à ces facteurs s'ajoute
une véritable inégalité de traitement à
savoir jusqu'à aujourd'hui des teneurs
en suc qui ne sont pas les mêmes dans
certaines denrées alimentaires
distribués entre l'hexagone et
l'Outremer or cette problématique de
teneur en sucre élevé des produits prod
alimentairire de consommation courante
revê une importance vitale en terme de
santé publique dans les territoire
d'outrem où l'obésité représente un
véritable fléo sans commune mesure avec
la situation sanitaire dans l'Hexagone
par exemple en Martinique le constat est
très inquiétant avec un enfant sur qu
atteint d'obésité à titre d'illustration
une canette de soda contient 14 g de
sucre ajouté Martinique contre 10 g sur
le territoire métropolitain idem pour
yaourt qui contient 15,8 g de glucide
dans l'Hexagone contre 20 g en
Guadeloupe pourtant ce n'est pas faute
d'avoir essayé de palier à cette
situation il y a quelques années
l'Agence française de sécurité sanitaire
des aliments a supprimé la collation du
matin dans les écoles car elle pouvait
favoriser l'augmentation de l'obésité en
2000 1 une circulaire avait tenté
d'interdire les distributeurs de
friandises et de boissons sucrées dans
les établissements scolaires mais elle
s'était heurté au proviseurs ainsi
qu'aux parents d'élèves qui considéraent
que les distributeurs limitaient les
sorties des élèves pendant les
interclasses par ailleurs de plus en
plus de scientifiques et de médecins
affirment que la menace constitué par la
consommation excessive de sucre en
particulier du cuctose et du glucose est
telle qu'elle justifie la mise en place
de mesures comparables à celles prises
pour limiter la consommation de tabac et
d'alcool en effet c'est ce sucre raffiné
que nous consommons dans les aliments
industriels qui provoquent une certaine
dépendance et un appauvrissement des
défenses immunitaires et que dire de
certains industriels qui ont justifié la
nature plus sucrée de leur le produit
par un plus grand attrait des
populations d'outreem pour le sucre de
telles aberrations se passent de
commentaires enfin concernant la date
limite de consommation àosée sur les
yaahou j'étis heureux de constater qu'il
en avait été pris bonne note dans ce
présent texte comme je vous l'avais
demandé monsieur le ministre dans une de
mes questions écrite en décembre dernier
puisqu'il est impensable et injuste que
les yaourts fabriqués en fr hexagonal et
expédié dans les domes est une DLC
différente de celle des mêmes yaaho
vendu en métropole je tiens à rappeler
brièvement monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues ma préoccupation puisque
certains fabricants de métropole
allongent la DLC en lapportant à 60
jours afin que les produits arrivant en
notre mer soient commercialisables et
restent donc à la vente plus longtemps
en rayon dans les magasins
d'alimentation je rappelle que la durée
de vie vie d'un aliment est défini comme
la période durant laquelle un produit
répond à des spécifications en terme de
sécurité inocquité et de salubrité
absence d'altération dans les conditions
prévues de stockage et d'utilisation y
compris par le consommateur c'est ce qui
s'appelle la date limite de consommation
DLC qu'il faut distinguer de la date
limite d'utilisation optimale la
DLUO la durée de vie d'un produit dépend
donc de ces caractéristiques
physico-chimiques qui résultent de
différents facteurs tels que la nature
des ingrédients le procédé de
fabrication le type de de
conditionnement et les modalités de
conservation ainsi il est anormal qu'un
produit fabriqué en métropole ait une
DLC à 55 60 jours quand les produits
locaux identiques sont soumis à une DLC
à 30 jours ce qui conduit à avoir des
produits fabriqués et
et importés qui affiche une DLC plus
longue qu'un produit fabriqué
ultérieurement cette pratique constitue
donc pour les producteurs de yaoud et
d'homme une atteinte au libre jeu de la
concurrence et revit dès lors un
caractère déloyal au sens de la
législation nationale et européenne je
me réjouis donc que le gouvernement a
pris la pleine mesure de cette injustice
et qu'il est introduit dans ce texte par
voix d'amendement un alignement de la
DLC des yaho vendu outre mer sur celle
des yaho vendu en métropolitaine
monsieur le ministre je tiens toutefois
à nuancer mes propos puisque si je suis
favorable à une DLC commune entre la
métropole et l'outrem je m'inquiète des
conséquences que pourrait avoir ce texte
sur le pouvoir d'achat du consommateur
ultramarin en effet je sais à quel point
le gouvernement était soucieux de lutter
contre la vie chère dans nos
départements puisque nous avons adopté
dernièrement une loi dans ce but
cependant l'alignement des DLC pour les
Yarou mais aussi pour l'ensemble des
produits frais et autres denrées
périssables risque d'entraîner une
hausse des prix de revien de plus de 250
%. comme vous le savez les DLC des
produits frais de métropole ne sont pas
soumis à la contrainte du temps de
transport qui représente de 15 à 25
jours pour le transport maritime en
direction des domes et l'importation de
ces mêmes produits par avion
renchérirait inévitablement les prix une
telle issue serait vous en conviendraz
contraire à l'esprit des actions que
nous avons engagé contre la chireté de
la vie au regard de ces éléments
pouvez-vous monsieur le ministre me
préciser les mesures envisagées par le
gouvernement pour garantir une sécurité
sanitaire maximale tout en évitant une
hausse des prix de ces produits frais je
vous
remercie merci Monsieur l'archer la
parole est à Monsieur Jacques cornano
pour le groupe
socialiste monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues c'est bien la première
fois que nous évoquons les questions
relatives à la qualité de l'offre
alimentaire notre mère dans cette
hémicycle en tant que président de la de
la délégation sénatoriale à l'outreem je
m'en félicite car il s'agit de problème
au combien important pour le devenir de
nos territoires et de nos
populations en plus de limiter la teneur
en sucre des produits consommés en notre
mère nos collègues députés ont avec
raison élargi le champ de cette
proposition de cette proposition de loi
à la question de la date limite de
consommation des derés périssables ce
qui est un pas de plus dans l'égalité de
traitement avec les consommateurs
hexagonaux notre débat aujourd'hui sur
cette proposition de loi visant à
garantir la qualité de l'offre
alimentaire autre ma arrive à point
nommé en effet année après année
scandale après scandale l'actualité est
venue tristement nous démontrer à quel
point nous vivons dans une contad à cet
égard plus les normes sont rigoureuses
en vue de protéger le consommateur plus
on découvre à quel point certains
exploitants ne se soucient de rien
d'autre que de leur marge bénéficiaire
ainsi aux Antill nous vivons sous la
menace d'un puissant poison la
chlorécone dont la rémanence va altérer
la santé de 10 prochaines
générations le problème c'est que que
nous ne mourons pas seulement des
pesticides avec lesquels nos terres et
nos eaux ont été pollué nous nous
mourons également des choix qui sont
faits délibérément quant à la
composition de nos produits alimentaires
industriels de quoi s'agit-il un produit
compara les denrées alimentaires
fabriqués en outre prère contiennent
généralement plus de sucre que celle
produite en Europe ceci est
particulièrement vrai s'agissant des
produits laitiers des sodas et des jus
de fruits question de goût répondre des
industriels les produits sont plus
sucrés parce que cela correspondrait à
une attente du consommateur
ultraamarin il ne faut pas confondre
attente et besoin
l'attente c'est le besoin réinterprété
par celui qui l'exprime il ne faut pas
non plus confondre attente et habitude
que les consommateurs ultramarins aient
l'habitude de consommer plus sucré c'est
un fait que cette habitude soit
assimilée à une attente c'est tout à
fait autre chose d'où nous vient cette
habitude donc d'abord de l'histoire même
de nos contré la Martinique la Guyane la
Guadeloupe pardon la Réunion ont été
souvent appelés des îles à sucre jusqu'à
l'avènement de la betterave ces colonies
fournissaient à la métropole l'ensemble
du sucre dont elle avait besoin de ce
fait la monoculture du sucre jusqu'à
dans les années 50 60 à dessiné le
paysage et former les goûts il est
normal qu'on mange beaucoup plus sucré
plus de sucre là où son accès est
abondant et aisé l'autre caractéristique
de nos pays tropicaux est donc chaud et
humide c'est qu'avant l'électricité les
moyens de réfrigération moderne il
n'existait que trois façons d'assurer la
conservation des aliments les
épices le sel et le sucre cette
contrainte a forgé nos goûts et notre
relation particulière avec le très épicé
le très salé et le donc le très sucré
tout cela ne serait qu'anecdotique si
c'était sans conséquence mais ça n'est
pas sans conséquence vous avez donc tous
noté dans les rapports qui ont été qui
vous ont été adressés les conséquences
de cette alimentation la propension à
l'obésité la prévalence du diabète et la
fréquence des maladies
cardioovasculaires et des accidents cul
vasculaire cérébux il est donc évident
il il est donc vital de changer ses
habitudes alimentaires à cette égard
l'argument des industriels selon lequel
la consom le consommateur les
consommateurs n'achèteront plus le
produit 6 le tau de suc est diminué
n'est pas recevable il n'est pas
recevable car nous savons tous que
passer les premières semaines peu
frustrante nous sommes capables
d'ajuster nos habitudes alimentaires il
n'est pas recevable car ce que prévoit
ce texte ce n'est pas que les produits
soient sousdotés en sucre pour
l'outreemè mais tout simplement que les
produits dosés soi soit dosé à l'égal
des autres régions de France de France
hexagonale enfin il n'est pas recevable
tout court et tout simplement parce
qu'aucun argument économique je dis bien
aucun argument économique ou commercial
ne peut primer sur une question de santé
publique chers collègues par conséquent
je vraai sans éiter ce texte je
vousci merci Monsieur l'archer dernier
orateur inscrit Monsieur Jacques cornano
pour le groupe
socialiste monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre chers
collègues la proposition de loi qui est
aujourd'hui soumise à notre étude rev
une importance essentielle en terme de
santé publique pour les collectivités
d'outrem mais la santé publique n'est
pas le seul enjeu en effet à l'heure où
sont étudiés par le Parlement la gestion
des déchets et le gaspillage alimentaire
notre réflexion doit être id par
l'objectif global de développement
durable mon sentiment en étudiant les
problématiques soulevées par les dates
limites de consommation et dates limite
d'utilisation optimale des produits
alimentaires à l'occasion de ce texte
est que nous ne faisons
qu'entrevoir un problème sanitaire
beaucoup plus vaste à l'échelle
nationale et que les pratiques des
industrielles de la l'agroalimentaire
sur les marchés des collectivités d'utr
m sont
symptomatiques les questions que nous
soulevons aujourd'hui relative au taux
de sucre et aux dates de consommation
des produits vendus outrem concerne
également la gouvernance de l'économie
locale et montre bien encore une fois
lesultés pour nos collectivités à
trouver les moyens de favoriser la
production locale et le contrôle des
produits l'article 4 du du présent
projet constitue de ce point de vu une
bonne avancée mais il aurait été
possible d'aller plus loin je reviendrai
là-dessus tout à
l'heure afin que la loi garantie de la
qualité de l'OF alimentaire en areemè
soit à la hauteur de sa formulation il
est nécessaire que la réflexion soit a
poursuivi au-delà du texte que les
mesures futures soient encore plus
ambitieuses et que nous poursuivons nos
résistance aux injections de certains
lobbyes industriels et je dis bien
certains car il est inutile de
stigmatiser les industriels de
l'agroalimentaire ni de leur faire
supporter la charge de tous les
problèmes de santé publique et
d'inégalité de traitement entre les
consommateurs ultramarins et
métropolitain mais chacun doit prendre
ses
responsabilités et la responsabilité des
pouvoirs publics est donc d'intervenir
pour faire cesser ces pratiques qui ne
sont certes pas illégales puisque
justement celles-ci ont pu perdurer
notamment en raison du vide juridique en
la matière ceci est aussi l'occasion
pour moi de souligner à nouveau les
incohérences d'un système
et l'on veut absolument soumettre aux
règles de droit rédigé pour la métropole
des territoires danst les contextes
notamment environnementaux sont
différents est-il normal que les
producteurs et industriels ultramarins
soient soumis aux mêmes réglementation
des guides de bonnes Prati d'hygiène que
les industriels métropolitains peut-être
qu'avec desnmes diff à l'égard de nos
industriels précéder d'études
scientifiques adaptées au milieu
naturels différents de la métropole le
plus souvent des milieux tropicaux nous
n serions pas là par ailleurs je suis
certain qu'il sera bien utile de nous
réunir à nouveau d'ici quelques temps
pour réétudier les impacts pratiques de
la présente loi et de revoir les
dispositifs de sanction à l'encontre de
C de ceux qui auraient trouvé des
stratégies pour contourner la
loi le texte de loi qui nous est soumis
constitue une bonne avancée et nous
montre la politique volontariste menée
par le gouvernement à l'égard des outr
Maes par conséquent je le voterai je
vous remercie de votre attention merci
mon cher collègue monsieur le rapporteur
vouliez la
parole vous
l'avez
oui mais mes chers collègues monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je je
constate que sur le diagnostique nous
sommes tous d'accord et ce qui ressort
de l'intervention de mon collègue guerot
et et Alain Milon c'est précisément euh
les solutions sur les solutions nous
divergeons moi je voudrais témoigner de
de notre bonne foi et de la bonne foi à
tous ceux qui se sont penchés sur sur ce
dossier
mon collègue nous avons totalement
épuisé les voix de
concertation et je suis je pèse mes mots
vous faisiez allusion tout à l'heure à
au au plans nationaux nutrition santé il
y en a eu trois cela fait 13 ans qu'on
est sur cette démarche 2001 2013 12 ans
le dernier en date
c'est le
pnss3 le
pnns3 doublé d'un plan obésité
spécifiquement au
outrem qu'est-ce qu'il en est sorti
c'est unhémisme que de dire pas
grand-chose s'agissant des Chartres
d'engagement dont faisait allusion mon
collègue Milon tout à l'heure il en a eu
33 chartes de
signer une seule
concerné les domes sur le sucre c'était
avec non sur le sel pardonnez-moi voyez
un peu c'était avec créolaille sur la
sur la Réunion voyez qu'on était loin de
la
problématique donc des
efforts les industriels ont sûrement eu
certains d'entre eux la bonne volonté
d'en faire mais force de constater
qu'ils sont pas allés jusqu'au bout de
leur démarche parce qu'ils avaient peur
peut-être simplement de se mettre pieds
et point
lié dans un défaut de une concurrence
qui leur aurait été
déloyale et puis et puis et puis vous
appelez de tous vos vœux la loi de santé
publique c'était en 2009 qu'il fallait
la faire
comme vous vous étiez engagé en tout cas
le précédent gouvernement s'était engagé
il y a rien eu en 2009 on est en
2013 et les désordres de santé publique
se sont agravés depuis nous somm
pardonnez-moi un peu brutalement une
sous-population
française alors ne pas agir rapidement
relève de la me semble-t-il de la non
assistance à population en danger il
faut agir et seulle la la régulation
publique peut faire cela c'est un un
devoir que nous avons si nous voulons
vraiment envoyer un message fort aux
population domienne le respect le
respect le simple respect de ces
populations je crois que cela est
devient urgent de de le faire je
voudrais simplement dire que nous avons
nous nous sommes attaqués à à un gros
problème sur les domes la triple peine
produit plus cher produit aujourd'hui
plus sucré produit plus vieux et
félicitons-nous-en que le gouvernement
apporte à cette triple peine des des
réponses c'est du
pragmatisme merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre vous souhaitez
répondre aux différents intervenants je
vous en
prieimis remercier tous les
parlementaires tous les sénateurs vous
toutes et vous tous ici présent qui
avait participé à ce à ce débat nourri
merci à vous merci à la présidente de la
Commission et au rapporteur monsieur
Vergos qui vient d'ailleurs de m'aider
dans une réponse qui sera faite tout à
l'heure je me permettrai de renvoyer mes
réponses sur l'article 3 relative à la
DLC il y a beaucoup de questions et qui
ont été posées sur les dattes limites de
consommation et les dattes limites
d'utilisation optimale donc on aura un
débat peut-être plus approfondi plus
précis en doit sur cette question là
vous me permettrez de commencer tout
d'abord par une différence disons
philosophique je dirais pas idéologique
j'ai entendu l'un des vôtres je crois
monsieur
Millon évoquer l'obésité qu'il s'agirait
là d'un problème de comportement un
problème
comportemental nous avons là une vraie
différence euh une vraie différence
comme si c'était laissé à la seule
responsabilité individuelle bien sûr il
il va de cela on peut pas dire le
contraire mais ignorer ce qui se passe
depuis toujours les choses qui sont
imposé et la distinction faite par le
sénateur Larcher est ce point de vue
éclairante à savoir entre habitude et
attente dire que les gens achètent
librement les mauvais produits à
mauvaise qualité nutritionnelle euh vous
me permettrez de ne pas partager ce
point de vue c'est un problème
d'inégalité vous avez un petit revenu
vous êtes un économiquement faible comme
on dit de manière fort affreuse et bien
vous allez acheter en fonction de vos
capacités de vos possibilités de vos
ressources et vous allez hélas acheter
les mauvais produits et donc les
produits peut-être les plus salés les
plus sucrés peut-être les plus les plus
gras bon on peut dire ça par ailleurs je
fais appel à mon expérience personnelle
moi dans les années 50 et 60 je n'avais
pas le sentiment même si on avait de la
canne à sucre à côté que je mangeais
sucré plus sucré peut-être plus salé
mais ce n'a jamais été une habitude de
consommation j'entends aujourd'hui alors
qu'à l'époque les études
épidémiologiques n'existaient pas encore
et bien 40 ans plus tard on vient nous
dire mais c'est une habitude acquise
depuis longtemps parce que vous êtes des
territoires à sucre mais mon dieu on a
la betterave ici dans les hexagone
est-ce pour autant on consomme plus de
sucre parce qu'on a la méraave et on en
tire du sucre que je sache non non il y
a des imposition culturelle il y a des
préférences de structure qui sont
imposées des des euh qualités qui hélas
de mauvaises qualités qui sont imposées
à la consommation et ça devient hélas
une habitude et non pas une attente et
bien l'attente aujourd'hui avec le
niveau euh euh éducationnel qui a progré
les gens attendent autre chose les gens
veulent mieux consommer et à des prix
raisonnables voilà ce que cette loi
d'ailleurs je me permettrai de dire sans
pour autant être enthousiaste cette loi
réunit plusieurs qualités premièrement
c'est vrai s'attaquer et garantir autant
que cela est possible la qualité de
l'offre alimentaire mais on n' pas
l'ambition d'épuiser le sujet il y a
bien autre chose pour garantir mieux
améliorer la la qualité de de l' offrees
alimentaire mais il faut quand même
commencer donc déjà garantir une
meilleure qualité sur ces deux aspects
là ces deux petits points là mais qui
nous paraissent considérables mais en
même temps avoir un développement plus
durable plus écologique plus soutenable
et puis disons l' TR clairement
développer aussi la production locale
tout en respectant la législation
européenne et la législation nationale
que souhaiter de mieux lorsque que on
réunit ce que d'cun pourrait croire euh
qu'il s'agirait de la quadrature du
cercle et bien on est très heureux de
pouvoir réunir en un texte bref où il y
a peu de décret c'était ça aussi un
souci on l'a fait dans une première loi
portant régulation économique outreem
peu de décret a je crois il y en a
quatre au total là il y aura un arrêté
et la loi sera donc immédiatement
applicable disons-le on espère qu'à
terme on espère qu'à terme et bien la
production locale pourra se développer
et que au lieu d'importer de la viande
fraîche on importera cette viande de des
yaourt frais on importera peut-être euh
du lait on fera sur place au lieu
d'avoir du jambon euh euh frais importé
et bien on va importer de la viande on
fera euh du jambon et par ailleurs euh
vous avez une liste celle-là que vous
avez tous reçu c'est l'industrie
agroalimentaire qui vous envoyé ça ce
sont les commerçants qui vous ont envoyé
ça je peux vous dire c'est édifi mais on
en parlera tout à l'heure sur l'article
3 c'est édifiant et ben vous verrez que
la plupart des produits notamment les
produits les plus périssables
microbiologiquement fragiles et bien
sont à 30 jours 25 30 jours ce qui est
parfaitement possible par voie maritime
cell et ceux qui s'autorisent de cela en
disant que il faut nécessairement faire
venir par avion et que ça multiplierait
les prix par 2,5 j'aientend entendu les
sénateurs Antist pardonnez-moi de dire
ça c'est un argument des industriels et
des commerçants ça va jouer sur quelques
produits les crèmes et autres
euh dessert chocolaté quelqu produit
qu'on peut compter sur les 300 que
l'industrie s'est autorisé à vous
envoyer mais à mon sens c'est très
contre-productif et ce n'est pas probant
du tout en tout cas ce serait plutôt le
contraire donc je tenais à dire ça nous
partons peut-être de point de vue opposé
en tout cas philosophiquement opposé
l'obésité n'est pas simplement le
résultat d'un comportement individuel
c'est aussi des choix qui sont imposés
c'est aussi des choix qui sont faits par
d'autres et qui sont imposés à des
consommateurs en situation de faiblesse
je me permets de le dire pour répondre
plus précisément euh au sénateur Vergos
et mais aussi au sénateur monsieur
Roquier sur les moyens de laadd CCRF oui
euh j'ai plaidé la semaine dernière
encore et je participe assez activement
je le crois à la loi portée par mon
collègue Benoît amont pour que
premièrement on renforce les pouvoirs
des agents de la DDCCRF et deuxièmement
et bien que il y a là aussi une
priorisation donnée à ce ministère pour
que ces lois-là ne soient pas des lois
un peu vides dont l'application ne
serait pas euh contrôlé nous sommes
conscients euh de ce risque là le
sénateur euh euh guerux sur attendre la
grande loi de santé publique le sénateur
Vergos a déjà répondu cette loi
d'ailleurs au mieux elle sera en 1er
semestre
2014 je vous dis lorsque nous avons
connu la réalité des chiffres de la
prévalence de certaines pathologies et
pas simplement l'obésité les
caridentaires les maladies cardio
vasculaires le le diabète l'hypertension
artérielle et j'en passe lorsque l'étude
épidémiologique podium porté par des
médecins ici et dans les autres mers on
ces études ont été connues nous avons
tout de suite déposé une proposition de
loi c'était en 2011 nous sommes en 2013
rien n'a été fait la question m'a été
posée pourriez-vous nous informer des
progrès engrangé par la signature des
chartes nutritionnelles les p2ns nous
sommes à tr édition je me permettrai de
vous dire de de manière un peu brutale
rien euh rien je le dis comme je le
pense rien je peux vous dire j'ai été
attentif à la signature de ces chartes
et bien il y a une accélération parce
que on se rend compte que la loi sera
probablement adoptée par cette majorité
et aussi avec une abstention j'espère
constructive je crois constructive
disons ça comme ça qu'elle sera adoptée
mais rien n'a été fait il y a une petite
accélération où on nous dit on va nous
faut 4 ou 5 ans pour commencer à
diminuer les taux de sucre bon très bien
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas incompatible
d'avoir cette loi avec si je dire des
seuils à minima les chartes peuvent
toujours faire mieux ce n'est pas du
tout incompatible enfin pourquoi vouloir
différer ce qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui
autre argument je l'ai souvent entendu
marteler et répété ici même au cours du
présent débat à savoir que ça relève du
réglementaire et on ne peut en aucun cas
s'en remettre à la loi permettez-moi de
contester cette cet argument là vous
touchez messieurs et mesdames les
sénateurs vous touchez à la liberté des
collectivité c'est la libre
administration territoriale l'article 4
par exemple c'est la libre
administration territoriale Vous ne même
si le code des marché était un code
plutôt de nature réglementaire lorsqu'il
s'agit de ces rapports pour le privé et
pour d'autres types de marché mais
lorsqu'il s'agit des rapports avec les
collectivités vous porter atteinte à une
liberté fondamentale celle de la libre
administration territoriale mais par
ailleurs lorsque vous commencez à
légiférer sur la liberté d'entreprendre
et la liberté d'échange et de commerce
là aussi ce sont des principes à valeur
constitutionnell que vous ne saiez
rédigé par décret vous ne pourriez faire
ça vous voyez un décret décider que je
vous somme d'intégrer dans les critères
de marché public les critères de
performance
euh ça pourrait être cassé à tout moment
ça pourrait faire l'objet de contentieux
et donc cet argument là avait été évoqué
longuement dans un rapport que vous
pourrait vous procurer celle qui avait
celui qui avait été fait à l'époque en
octobre 2011 où tous les arguments de
droit constitutionnels avaient été
évoqués et on s'était rangé à cette
position là ça relève de la loi euh
madame archembo la crainte sur un arrêté
ministériel vous avez raison j'avoue que
j'ai eu le même doute que vous je je je
le dis mais il y a plusieurs ministres
c'est vrai intéressés donc je prends ici
l'engagement comme je l'ai fait pour
pour la loi portant régulation
économique donc contre la vie chè soit
prise deux décrets sont déjà pris
peut-être que le deuxème n'est pas
publié sur les observatoires des prix
des revenus et des marges euh
le on discute sur la tarification
bancaire donc on devrait très rapidement
avoir publié les quatre décrets du de la
précédente loi en tout cas ça marche ça
s'applique et ça fait l'objet déjà de
contrôle et de bilan à mi-étape là il y
aura un arrêté à prendre oui il faudra
faire très vite d'ailleurs la loi a été
réécrite pour éviter trop de
lenteur parce que à l'époque
on se disait qu'il fallait fixer par la
Haute Autorité en santé publique il me
semble des
taux plafond
maximum là c'était un peu compliqué là
on a pris une moyenne c'est vite
fait et j'espère qu'on pourra très
rapidement publier ce texte là
sur le risque de concurrence déloyale
entre entreprises françaises et
étrangères là j'ai aussi souvent entendu
cette
argument plusieurs réponses premièrement
les produits intéressés ils sont peu
nombreux mais c'est pas un argument
juridique mais ils sont peu nombreux il
s'agit de niche et donc ça ne remettrait
pas en cause si je dire la situation de
l'industrie nationale il s'agit en
particulier des desserts industriels par
exemple contenant de la crème et et et
et des ufs de la charcuterie fraîche et
là l'argument que j'ai évoqué il y a un
moment s'appliquerait donc ça me remet
pas fondamentalement en cause la
situation concurrentielle de l'industrie
hexagonale enfit les circuits rapides
vers les outremers se font à partir des
ports français les produits étrangers
part donc avec un fort handicap
concurrentiel en terme de délis enfin
plutôt que de tenir à à bout de bras un
système de gaspillage à notre sens et je
l'ai dit il faut mieux favoriser la
production locale les circuits courts
les produits euh frais donc ces produit
là la production locale elle n'a aucun
problème de de livraison mais ça n'a pas
été fait dans un optique
protectionniste ça n'a pas été fait pour
ça par ailleurs je finirai et c'est la
la l'industrie agroalimentaire qui nous
a envoyé récemment ce dossier Lania qui
reconnaît que la directive
européenne je crois
2002 permet à tout État européen la
possibilité
pour les états déédicter des
dispositions nationales plus
restrictives en matière de consommation
et de date limite de consommation cela
s'appliquera à toutes les entreprises
européennes et donc ça ne devrait pas là
non plus souffrir de longue
contestation je crois
avoir répondu à à toutes les euh
questions y compris à celle du sénateur
Antiste sur la possible augmentation euh
des prix euh et là euh c'est un argument
qui a été martelé avant que la loi
n'arrive aujourd'hui euh devant vous on
vous a envoyé et je vous invite à lire
ça vraiment vous verrez euh dans ce
tableau envoyé par l'industrie et la
distribution la liste des produits 300
produits qui apparemment seraient
concerné euh par euh ces dates limite de
consommation les DLC export par exemple
je prends les les crèmes vanillé euh 28
jours à l'export 19 jours en métropole
euh si il devait changer de mode de
transport mais ça c'est un calcul
interne fait par un groupe d'entreprises
euh
0,47 centimes le prix d' revient net euh
de à
l'export et le nouveau prix de revient
si ça devait passer à l'avion
0843 c'est leur
calcul et donc le prix de vente avant
qui est à 69 centimes passerait à 1,23 €
c'est leur calcul et tout à l'avenant et
c'est intéressant ces chiffres je vous
cacherai pas on les analysera on les
analysera et vous verrez qu'il y a
quelques surprises c'est pas du tout le
frit d'autant plus que lorsque l'on
prend les
dates limite de mation tel qu'il figure
là ça peut venir par bateau et ce qui
nous intéresserait c'est quelques
produit c'est peut-être cette première
page à savoir les desserts comme ils le
disent eux-mêmes pour le reste
l'argument ne tient pas la route et que
c'est un argument de groupe de pression
que je peux entendre mais que je
n'approuve nullement et c'est la raison
pour laquelle en réponse sur la question
3 je sais que les questions viennent je
ferai disons-le comme ça une déclaration
interprétative de l'article 3 de la
proposition de loi qui vous soumise
merci à vous tous et à vous
toutes merci monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues la discussion générale
est clause nous allons passer à la
discussion du texte de la commission et
à l'article 1er et je suis saisi d'une
demande de parole de Monsieur Jacques
cornano pour le groupe
socialiste si je ne suis pas pour une
inflation législative qui restiendrait
les libert de chacun de consommer ce
qu'il souhaite et comme il le souhaite
force de constater que la possibilité
offerte aux producteurs de prévoir les
taux de suc qu'ils veulent dans les
produits alimentaires proposés à la
vente outrem constitue un véritable
scandale sanitaire les données
épidémiologiques sont alarmantes mais
néant moins insuffisante quant aux
causes et conséquences à venir pour la
santé de nos compatri Quiot en areem la
surconsommation de sucrem est le
résultat direct de la volonté
d'accoutumer le consommateur ultramarin
à des taux de sucre élevés dans les dans
les denrées qu'il consomme
quotidiennement et je le dis il faut que
chacun assume ses
responsabilités je souhaite souligner
deux éléments qui me semblent importants
tout d'abord ord la nécessité de mener
une étude d'ampleur sur l'impact en
matière de santé obésité et ses
conséquences diabète et les maladies
cardio-vasculaires notamment résultant
de l'absence de contraintte pesant sur
les producteurs en matière de suc
utilisé dans les produits alimentaires
vendus
autrem comme le souligne le rapport
réalisé par notre collègue hlène
vainqueur Christophe rapporteur pour la
commission des affaires sociales à
l'Assemblée nationale les mesures prises
dans le cadre de la lutte contre
l'obésité révèle des insuffisances sans
autreem le rapport dit concernant le
Plan National Nutrition Santé adapté à
l'utreemère force de constater que plus
d'un an après son lancement la
traduction concrète sur le terrain de
nombre de ces mesures se fait encore
attendre et semble bien impuissante à
enrayer les tendances à l'œuvre ensuite
alors que l'avenir de l'éducation en
France est au cœur des débats il me
semble indispensable de réfléchir au
moyens d'éduquer nos enfants à la bonne
hygiène élémentaire et notamment
d'introduire dans les programmes
d'éducation à la santé et à la
citoyenneté une éducation nutritionnelle
spécifique à l'autreemère afin que les
jeunes populations soi éveillé quant à
la composition et aux apports
nutritionnels des produits qui leur sont
opposé à la consommation sur le marché
de la collectivité d'utr mè où ils
vivent donc voilà les éléments que je
voulais apporter pour l'article 1 merci
merci mon cher collègue monsieur
Antoinette monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues le bien
manger et le bien boire y compris dans
leur mission de lien social font partie
d'un SOC culturel commun à la France de
la métropole aux autres mers et en somme
bien partagé par de nombreuses couches
de la
population la complexité des circuits
modernes de production et de
commercialisation alimentaire et la
difficulté accrue de la traçabilité des
produits de consommation en dépit de
l'arsenal juridique ayant évolué en
faveur du contrôle de la qualité à créé
des disparités inacceptables entre les
territoires de la République mais de
surcrois de graves problèmes de santé
publique et en particulier en Arom non
pas en raison d'éventuelles contraintes
techniqu mais tout simplement sous la
pression de groupes d'intérêt économique
et
financiers le résultat médioque comme
comme cela comme cela a été rappelé par
le rapporteur des chartes d'engagement
de progrès nutritionnel dans le domaine
de la réduction de la teneur des sucs
ajoutés met en lum
la résistance des industriels avec la
complicité des précédents
gouvernements contre l'amélioration de
l'offre nutritionnelle en are m cette
absence d'alignement volontaire indique
également la voie à suivre l'inscription
dans une norme obligatoire
elle souligne encore une exigence celle
de vérifier que les producteurs ne
tentont pas en modifiant l'apparence de
leur offre de continuer leur pratique
malsaines l'article 1er en introduisant
en introduisant pardon la notion de dré
similairire permettra une réalisation
effective de cet alignement entre la
métropole et les autres mère s'il s'agit
de valoriser les circuits de production
et de commercialisation locaux inscrits
dans le respect des normes sanitaire
défin au niveau national c'est une
véritable avancée juridique à la
à la hauteur des enjeux de développement
des autres mèes car la préférence locale
ne se fonde pas sur des lobbyes mais sur
la stricte application du cadre
législatif et
réglementaire voilà pourquoi au-delà de
tout l'argumentaire développé par mes
collègues sur les enjeux sanitaires de
l'offre alimentaire en are mer surpoids
obésité maladie cardiovascula diabète
j'entire un enseignement politique et
idéologique
majeur la la gauche humaniste aux
affaires est la seule à même de placer
les femmes les hommes et les territoires
de la République à la fois au centre des
préoccupations en même temps que dans un
destin partagé voilà les raisons de mon
soutien appuyé à cet
article merci Monsieur
guerot monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues égard aux
excellents arguments apportés par mon
collègue le rapporteur vergot
et puis
aussi l'unanimité qui se fait sur le nos
ban par nos représentants de l'outr
maire le groupe udi et UC votera
favorablement cette proposition de
loi merci je vais donc mettre au voix
l'article 1er quels sont ceux qui sont
pour son
adoption avis
contraire abstention il est adopté même
vote pour l'article
2 même vote il est adopté article 3 j'ai
une demande de parole de Monsieur
cornano monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues à consommé
jusqu'au à consommeré avant le à
consommeré de préférence avant l'UR ces
mençons figurent sur les emballages de
nos produits alimentaires mais comment
savoir ce qu'elle signifie
réellement la problématique fondamentale
revê un double aspect à savoir comment
concilier nos préoccupations relatives à
la santé et celui de relever les défis
environnementaux que génèent le
gaspillage alimentaire les enjeux de la
lutte contre ce gaspillage sont la
réduction de l'impact environnemental de
l'alimentation l'aide aux personnes les
plus démunies et l'optimisation de
l'agriculture des jeu de développement
durable incontournable aujourd'hui je
pense que la question du gaspillage
alimentaire s'inscrit dans une réflexion
d'ensemble à mener pour l'avenir de
notre société et non seulement à l'égard
des autres mèes si je me félicite que
nous étudions le problème posé par la
vente de produits alimentaires
différemment daté selon qu'il soit vendu
en métropole ou autre m je reste
dubitatif sur le problème dans son
ensemble soit des produits alimentaires
sont distribués autreem et au mieux si
je puis dire ceux-ci sont dénués de
qualité
organoleptique et nutritionnel sans
constituer un danger immédiat pour la
santé soit nous sommes en présence d'un
véritable scandale environnemental
économique et social en France résultat
d'un gaspillage alimentaire
institutionnalisé et les pouvoirs
publics sont tout aussi responsables que
les industriels de l'AG alimentaire
parce qu'il les laisse faire il apparaît
en effet que si nous sommes confrontés à
de tels problèmes c'est essentiellement
en raison du vide juridique lié à
l'absence de dispositions légales et
réglementaires concernant les DLC
dlo alors il apparaît que le problème
doit être réfléchi en amont et qu'il
nous faille pourquoi pas repenser toute
la méthodologie d'évaluation et de
validation des documentations sur
lesquelles se fondent les professionnels
de secteur en attendant cette refonte
plus profonde et salutaire du système il
serait possible d'introduire une
obligation de prévoir dans la rédaction
des guides nationaux de bonnes pratiques
et d'hygiène des moyens et méthodes à
mettre en œuvre afin de répondre aux
objectifs sanitaires des aliments à
l'égard des professionnels souhaitant
vendre leurs produits dans les
collectivités d'ut premère en effet
parmi les principes de la méthode achat
CCP système qui identifie évalue et
maîtrise les dangers significatifs au
regard de la sécurité des aliments
l'étude scientifique et les avis rendus
par les différents comités d'experts
spécialisés ne font quasiment jamais
mention de l'évolution des produits dans
les contextes naturel ultramarin il
s'agirait là d'un moyen de s'assurer de
la bonne analyse des dangers logique
identification caractérisation
exposition chimique ou physique à
prendre en compte en fonction des
produits ou production considéré et
procédés utilisés dans l'environnement
spécifique aux outromèes par ailleurs au
cours de la procédure de validation des
guides nationaux de bonnes pratiques et
d'hygiène les protocoles prévoient cinq
étapes dont la première prévoit la
notification du projet de guide aux
trois directions DGAL DGCCRF et DGS par
la branche de secteur et la désignation
d'une administration dite pilote par le
comité interministériel de suivi des
guides afin d'être l'interlocuteur
principal du professionnel sur le projet
de guide il me semble qu'il serait
indispensable que le ministre des outre
maire soit systématiquement associé aux
discussions entre l'administration
pilote et aux professionnels de secteur
les guides ont pour objectif d'aider les
professionnels de secteur à maîtriser la
sécurité sanitaire des aliments et
respecter leurs obligations
réglementaires alors pourquoi laisser
exclure de leur champ d'étude les
collectivités d'outr mè et risquer de
mettre en péril la santé de nos
concitoyens merci
merci Monsieur Serge
Larchet bien monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre madame la
Présidente de la Commission affffaires
sociales mon chers collègue rapporteur
mes chers collègues la tenur est le plus
élevé en suc de certains certaines
denrées alimentaires n'est pas la seule
différence entre le de traitement que
subissent les consommateur ultramarins
du fait de leur lieu de résidence comme
l'ont souligné nos collègues députés en
élargissant avec raison le champ de la
représente position de loi à la question
de la de la date limite de consommation
cette DLC indique une limite impérative
qui s'applique à des dré rapidement
périssable tel que les yarout
susceptible de présenter après de courte
période un danger immédiat pour la santé
du consommateur certains industriels
hexagonaux ont mis en place un système
de double étique taille selon la
destination de leur produit afin de
prendre en compte les délais de
transport par bateau ainsi le délai est
fixé à 30 jours après la fabrication
pour les yaourts distribués en métropole
et jusqu'à 55 jours pour le même produit
àcheminé outreem dans ces conditions on
peut se demander s'il est réellement
sans danger pour la santé humaine de
consommer un même produit jusqu'à 30
voire même 60 jours après sa fabrication
cette pratique choquante brûille
l'information mais surtout apparaît
inadmissible du point de vue de
l'égalité des doitts entre les
consommateurs de même territoire le
territoire français d'autre part
l'allogement de la DLC des yaout
fabriqué en métropole exporté vers les
département de tremè constitue une
pratique inéquitable car les producteurs
locaux les nôtres font quant à eux quant
à eux prévoi des délais de consommation
plus court afin de tenir compte des
facteurs susceptibles d'altérer la
qualité des produits après leur mise en
circulation on peut donc se trouver se
retrouver devant une situation
paradoxale où des produits importés dont
la dlc a ainsi été allongé péri plus
tard que des produits équivalents dont
la date de fabrication est plus récente
cette fosse c'est la fosse de manière
déloyale le choix de consommateur qui se
tourne généralement vers le produit
offrant la plus longue période de
consommation qui est synonye selon lui
de plus grande
fraîcheur monsieur le monsieur le
ministre je ne peut qu'approuver cet
article 3 et pour des raisons évidentes
de de santé publique mais je m'interroge
cependant sur le champ de cet article le
dispositif vise je cite le délai dans
lequel une denrée alimentaire doit être
consommé je souhaite savoir Monsieur le
Ministre si cette disposition ne
concerne que la date limite de
consommation DLC ou si elle s'étend aux
autres denrées alimentaires préemballés
présentant une relative stabilité
microbiologique qui selon la
rlementation européenne et française
d'étictetage doit faire apparaître une
date limite d'utilisation optimale la D
Luo en outre monsieur le ministre vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir et vous l'avez
évqué à l'instant que les distributeurs
des denrées alimentaires
outrem évoquent les conséquences de cet
alignement alignement des DLC entre
autre m et métropole cette nécessaire
mesure de santé publique engendrerait
selon eux une augmentation des prix de
ces produits outrem voire le complète
disparition des étales ils avancent que
le surcour engendré par la nécessaire
modification du mode d'acheminement
avion plutôt le bateau risquerait de
poser des problèmes monsieur le ministre
je c cette intervention vise à vous
faire réagir comme vous l'avez promis
sur cette cet article 3 de façon à lever
toute ambigué et que les choses soient
le plus clair possible il est bien
entendu pour n dans notre esprit que
rien ne peut primer la qualité la la
santé publique aucun argument commercial
ou bienquel ne peut primer sur l'état de
la santé publique voilà
merci merci merci mon cher collègue
monsieur le ministre vous avez souhaité
prendre la
parole merci monsieur le Président merci
à tous euh j'aimerais apporter
quelques complément parce que j'ai pas
répondu à tout le monde j'aimerais
euh dire que j'ai été très intéressé par
la comparaison historique qu' fait Félix
Desplan oui le sucre a été un peu à
l'origine de notre histoire et on sait
dans quelles conditions et que l'évoquer
aujourd'hui et bien me paraît tout à
fait indiqué pour mieux comment dire euh
domestiquer les choses parce que si le
sucre a été à l'origine de l'esclavage
on a fait venir du monde c'était pour
produire de la canne à sucre après le le
tabac le coton et tout ça ça a été la
canne à sucre et bien aujourd'hui il
faut pas que le sucre domine encore la
vie quotidienne et parfois l'avenir et
donc j'ai j'ai bien aimé cette
comparaison historique je rappellerai
aussi que lorsque les
inquiétudes se font ja
sur le fait que on aurait plus la
possibilité de consommer des produits
frais qu'il faudrait les faire venir par
avion ça multiplierait les prix on me
rappelle ici là que lorsque les
ultramarins exportent leurs produits ici
notamment la banane mais la nanas
Victoria parfois c'est aussi par fret
aérien et que le consommateur
métropolitain accepte de payer un peu
plus cher
pourquoi principe de symétrie si on veut
consommer des
produits frais venant de métropole il
faut oui peut-être accepter de payer un
chouya et je rappelle que ça concerne
peu de produits les desserts et
peut-être la charcuterie et moi
j'espère avec beaucoup d'autres que on
pourra faire de la substitution
d'importation et donc développer la
production locale j'ai contesté à une
époque
une conception du développement endogène
alors que lorsque j'étais étudiant
c'était un thème que nous aimions bien
on pensait même que ça relevait d'une
certaine philosophie qui était proche de
de la en tout cas de la mienne et bien
j'ai contesté ça parce que à l'époque
c'était pour dire il y a plus de
solidarité nationale il y a plus de
crédit débrouillez-vous bon là on donne
les moyens par par exemple la
restauration collective quel est le
problème des territoires au-delà de la
Guyane qui est dans un continent c'est
l'insularité c'est la dimension
l'étendue des marchés comme dirait Adam
Smith vous avez peu de population des
marchés peu
étendus si vous
arrivez par la destruction créatrice
peut-être et c'est ce qu'on fait ici en
métropole pourquoi croyez-vous que l'on
met 15 jours 19 jours pour le jambon
frais le jambon de Paris ou le jambon
blanc pourquoi croyez-vous alors qu'il
est encore consommable et bien ça permet
le maintenant IR l'activité ça permet de
faire tourner les usines ça permet de
maintenir l'emploi pourquoi ne peuton
pas répéter cet exemple à qui élargit le
marché au-delà des populations au-delà
de la taille des marchés derrière cette
loi il y a autre chose aussi il faut
donc donner les moyens à l'industrie de
se développer lorsque vous dites au aux
agriculteurs et aux
agrotransformateurs que vous aurez un
marché récurrent répétitif euh
de la restauration collective tous les
jours à la Réunion me Dison c'est 36
millions de ples sur l'année et ben vous
avez là un vrai marché euh euh avant de
faire dans l'exportation vous faites la
conquête de votre marché intérieur nous
n'allons pas sombrer dans l'illusion de
quroire qu'il y aura indépendance
alimentaire mais vous aurez fait la
conquête d'une part du marché intérieur
vous aurez assuré des développements
d'entreprises et des développements
d'emploi vous aurez un développement
moins émetteur de gaz à effet euh de
serre et je pense que tout cela
peut-être vertueux et donc je tenais à
euh vous apporter ce complément euh de
euh réponse une question a été posée je
peut-être pas saisi toute euh la
subtilité de la question sur les accords
de partenariat économique entre les
territoires ultramarins et euh le
voisinage disons immédiat euh il
faudrait peut-être que presque vous-même
vous avez fait ici au Sénat dans un
rapport qui a été remis peut-être faire
le bilan de cette affaire-là ces accords
n'ont pratiquement été signés nulle part
si ce n'est dans les soutrmers euh dans
la Caraïbe et peut-être dans l'océan
Indien parce que l'Afrique c'est un peu
insurgé en disant c'est asymétrique on
voit pas tout à fait nos intérêts donc
ils ont retenu leur plumes en revanche
dans la Caraïbe où nous n'étions pas
autour de la table à l'époque mon
président de région je m'étais invité au
sein du cari forum comme ils disent dans
la Caraïbe la machine de négociation je
m'étais invité
avec compatriote de la Martinique Crusol
qui représentait la Guadeloupe qui
représentait aussi la Martinique pour
être informé la chose a été signée avec
une asymétrie d'une période d'une
vingtaine d'années à peu près les
produits de la Caraïbe de 17 pays ACP et
PTOM de la Caraïbe qui peuvent entrer
librement en Guadeloupe Martinique guyan
Saint-Martin saint-bartelem encore que
saint-b demi c'est aujourd'hui un PTOM
qui peut donc si je dire légiférer et
réglementer en matière de commerce
extérieur
euh autant les personnes peuvent y aller
euh les Français peuvent y aller pas
dépenser leur épar dans un pays-l nos
produits ne peuvent pas y aller ce
heurtant à ce qu'on appelle à la
négative liste c'est une sorte de liste
de prohibition pour plus de 200 produits
qui ne peuvent pas entrer et entrer en
concurrence avec les produits de la car
mais c'est vrai aussi pour peut-être
pour l'océan Indien même s'il y a
peut-être pas des listes de prohibition
mais il y a là une asymétrie que le la
Commission européenne est libre de
contracter sans même l'accord euh de la
France parce que c'est le pouvoir propre
de la commission le pouvoir de
négociation dans le cadre de mandat
j'avoue que à l'époque euh la chose
n'avait pas été suffisamment expertisé
donc on reprend la chose et j'ai fait
nommer le Premier ministre a nommé
parlementaire en mission Serge lechimi
député de la Martinique pour faire des
propositions pour tenir compte de ces
accords de partenariat économique de
l'environnement immédiat de l'article
349 du traité sur le fonctionnement de
l'Union européenne et voir comment faire
avec et comment par endroit s'en
émanciper et donc là il y a euh je
l'espère de nouveaux textes à venir de
nouveaux accords à à trouver en tout cas
il a été décidé que quelle que soit la
liberté du pouvoir de négociation en
matière de commerce international de la
Commission de mieux tenir compte des
intérêts de ces territoires qui sont
aussi européens donc le bilatéral
peut-être catastrophique on l'a vu en
matière de banane de Rome de de riz en
Guyane on l'a vu donc il faut éviter de
signer trop vite sans évaluer les
conséquences en général il y a pas
d'étude d'impact et donc là on a a pu
s'en mordre les droits je tenais à
répondre de manière précise en lisant un
texte euh pour bien répondre aux
interpellations qui ont été faites et la
dernière par votre président de
délégation le sénateur Larcher
euh parce que j'aimerais qu'elle soit
interprétative et que demain on ne sait
jamais en cas de contentieux que ça
puisse euh éclairer peut-être le juge
euh d'abord je vous dire mon plein
accord avec le rapporteur Michel Vergos
sur son interprétation de l'article 3
qui le conduit à préciser que seul les
DLC les dates limit de consommation sont
concernés par cet article puisque la
date limite d'utilisation optimale DLUO
n'est précisément pas une date au-delà
de laquelle on ne peut plus consommer un
produit les inquiétudes de l'industrie
agroalimentaire qui défend l'utilisation
de DLUO spécifique à l'exportation sont
donc sans
fondement cet article ne vise que les
produits périssables dont la
durée de commercialisation n'est que de
quelques jours ou de quelques semaines
et qui sont soumis à une obligation
d'information sur leur délai impératif
de consommation pour des raisons de
sécurité sanitaire donc uniquement la
DLC mais même sur ce seul champ réduit
des produits soumis à DLC certains
distributeurs ont soulevé un argument
économique l'allongement de la DLC
serait nécessaire pour exporter par voie
maritime dans les oututres mers la voie
aérienne conduisant à un surcût trop
important quelle est la portée exacte de
cet argument quel produit vise--il
a-t-on soulevé un problème nouveau que
personne n'avait vu et quel est-il vous
avez été destinataire de ce dossier-là
je pense que vous le connaissez un peu
tous j'ai d'ailleurs entendu ici là des
arguments inspirés très largement euh de
cet argumentaire fait par l'industrie
agroalimentaire les distributeurs et les
euh commerçants une liste de 300 produit
soumis à double DLC et qui constituerait
le cœur du problème que nous révèle euh
cette liste d'abord elle nous révèle que
pour une trentaine de produits
essentiellement des desserts industriels
mousse au chocolat crème caramel hîle
flottante rizolet baba au Rome et cetera
la différence des DLC n'est que de
quelques jours quelques jours un si
faible écart conduit à s'interroger sur
la nécessité d'avoir deux dates vous le
verrez là la première page quelques
jours au plus une
semaine lorsque la DLC est de 17 à 21
jours en France et de 25 jours à
l'export alors on pourrait dire en
France hexagonal parce que nous sommes
considérés comme territoire
d'exportation donc on peut employer ces
catégories là 17 à 21 jours en France
hxagonal et de 25 jours à l'export on
est dans un ajustement assez fin si ces
desserts sont encore bons à 25 jours
pourquoi les jeter au bout de 17
jours c'est du gaspillage organisé mais
ça ça logique et le débat n'a pas été
été organisé mais sur ce sujetlà mais
pourquoi jeter à 17 jours il y a ensuite
toute une série de produits dans cette
liste notamment des produits laitiers
avec des DLC ordinaires à 25 jours et
des DLC export à 40 50 ou 60 jours là
franchement franchement je m'interroge
sur la logique des distributeurs ils
nous disent qu'une DLC export à 25 jours
c'est très bien pour vendre une mousse
au chocolat malgré le délai de frite
mais qu'une DLC à 25 jours pour des
yaourts ce n'est pas assez et ils
veulent 40 jours ça me paraît un peu
contradictoire j'ai la même
interrogation pour les tranches de
jambon cuit on entre dans le détail hein
je vois dans cette liste un jambon avec
une DLC de 15 jours en France
hexagonale et de 23 jour au dessert on
finit
de 15 jours en France hexagonale et de
23 jours à l'export qui voisine avec une
autre avec une DLC ordinaire de 27 jours
ici et de 40 jours à l'export ainsi on a
allongé la DLC de ce jambon de Paris
c'était ça de 23 jours pour l'export
mais elle reste plus courte que la DLC
normale du second euh c'était du jambon
blanc euh
pourquoi ne pas se contenter de vendre
le second dans les outremers j'ai là un
autre problème mais il y a mieux
peut-être il y a pire je vois dans cette
liste je l'ai dit déjà du Guillet rappé
avec une DLC normale à 40 jours bien
suffisante pour exporter un outre mer et
une DLC export à 180 jours 180 jours 6
mois pour un produit
frais avez-vous essayé de garder pendant
6 mois un P pa de Gouill rappé dans
votre frigo essayez et c'est ce que j'ai
entendu lorsque une parlementaire
aujourd'hui ministre n'a pas reconnu
c'est casber nous on a connu ça ça
piquait effectivement à l'époque en tout
cas faites l'expérience cela vous aidera
à vous faire une opinion sur les doubles
DLC je vois aussi un cber tiens
pasteurisé avec une DLC à 21 jours
portter à 70 jours à l'export et un
robelon avec une DLC normale à 35 jours
qui va jusqu'à 120 jours à l'export nous
savions que les ultramarins émettent
trop le sucre euh je vois que les
industriels pensent qu'il raffol aussi
du fromage r raffiné et qu'ils ont
l'estomac solide j'ai conservé pour la
fin les plaquettes de beurre avec une
DLC à 35 jours qui passe à
365 jours à l'export et oui ça c'est de
euh c'est Alfonse Allis ça hein passer
les bonnes il n'y a plus de limite hein
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ur
je ne sais pas si ces dates sont exactes
c'est ce qu'ils disent c'est ce qu'ils
nous ont envoyé c'est leur propre euh
chiffre mais ce sont celles que nous
donnent ces industriels qui contestent
la suppression de la double DLC pour
l'autre maire si la réalité de la
pratique est bien celle-là je crains que
la sécurité sanitaire n''est pas
grand-chose à voir dans cette affaire et
que ce DLC élastique ne soit que le
résultat d'un marketing irresponsable je
finirai c'est le même argument qui a été
employé pour le surdosage en sucre
lorsqu'on dit que c'est votre goût non
c'est un argument commercial parce que
ça crée la dépendance ça crée
l'addiction c'est aussi un facteur de
meilleure conservation de plus longue
conservation de plus longues séries donc
c'est essentiellement un problème de
profit mer ministre je vais mettre au
voix l'article 3 qui est pour son
adoption qui est contre abstention
l'article 3 est adopté sur l'article 4
j'ai une demande de prise de parole de
Monsieur Jacques cornano pour le groupe
socialiste vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues cet article
4 vise à promouvoir les denrées IIS des
circuits courts de distribution dans le
cadre de la passation des marchés
publics de restauration collective
outremè l'évolution du texte prévu par
l'Assemblée nationale est tout à fait
bienvenue et s'inscrit parfaitement dans
les objectifs de développement durable
nécessaires je précise qu'il s'agit né
enmoins déjà d'un critère d'OF de
passation de marché public que les
collectivités retiennent souvent sur
l'île de mariegalante c'est le cas et
nous faisons tout notre possible pour
que les producteurs locaux interviennent
au maximum dans la fabrication des repas
des restaurants scolaires toutefois je
tiens à souligner qu'il est nécessaire
d'aller plus loin ce que je ne manquerai
pas de faire notamment en proposant
l'élargissement de la mesure prévue pour
les produits frais locaux à des produits
locaux transformés ainsi qu'au produits
issu de l'agriculture biologique merci
merci mon cher collègue pas d'autre
demande de prise de parole je vais
mettre au voix l'article 4 qui est pour
qui est contre abstention l'article 4
est adopté je vais mettre au voix
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi y
a-t-il des demandes d'explication de
vote non monsieur le
rapporteur non je mets au voix
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
visant à garantir la de l'offre
alimentaire en outreem qui est pour son
adoption qui est contre
abstention
abstention merci la proposition de loi
est définitivement
adoptée monsieur le ministre vous avez
la parole juste un petit mot on parlera
plus de desser pour vous remercier tous
merci un vrai progrès vient d'être là
accompli j'ai bien entendu le sénateur
cornano on verra cet aspect cette
question l'article 4 qui pourrait être
étendu à d'autres produits d'autres
secteurs dans le cadre de la loi portée
par mon collègue Stéphane Lefol voilà
parce que on veut changer de modèle
passer d'un modèle intensif à un modèle
agroécologique si ça peut-être porter on
verra bien en tout cas merci à tous
voilà pour cette séance consacrée à la
qualité de l'offre alimentaire outrem si
vous souhaitez la revoir elle est
disponible en VOD sur notre site
internet
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous avec
les travaux parlementaires c'est cet
après-midi à partir de 16h30 avec la
suite de la discussion du projet de loi
sur la décentralisation bon après-midi à
tous